bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
de revoir deux auditions deux auditions
qui ont eu lieu la semaine dernière au
Sénat alors la première c'est celle
d'Hervé latsou le secrétaire général
adjoint de l'ONU en charge des opération
de maintien de la paix comme vous allez
pouvoir l'entendre lors de
l'introduction faite par le président de
la Commission des Affaires étrangères
Jean-Pierre affarin les sénateurs
veulent comprendre et interroger AR
là-dessous sur l'efficacité de ces 15
opérations de maintien de la paix dans
le monde comment s'articulle ces
opérations avec les armées locales mais
aussi avec les forces françaises sur le
terrain et enfin quel est le coût de ces
opérations voilà vous allez donc pouvoir
suivre en direct l'audition donc d'Hervé
latsou devant la commission des affaires
étrangères du Sénat mesdames et
messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très honoré de avoir
cette occasion de m'exprimer devant vous
et d'abord je vous présente mes vifs
regrets mais l'avion a pris 1 heure de
retard et donc ça nous a forcé à à
narriver ici que malheureusement à
l'instant en tout cas je suis heureux de
cette occasion de vous présenter à grand
trait ces opérations de maintien de la
paix si je puis me permettre monsieur le
Président en fait c'est 16 opérations 16
opérations qui rassemblent 125000 hommes
et femmes militaires policiers civils
euh pour certaines depuis très longtemps
la première opération de maintien de la
paix a été créé dans le contexte de la
première trêve entre Israël et ses
bisins arabes en 1948 et puis des
opérations beaucoup plus
contemporaines un mot tout de suite sur
le coût de ces opérations pour cet
exercice 8 milliard 200 millions de
dollars environ ce qui est beaucoup à l'
absolu une forte somme et en même temps
en comparaison c'est ce qu'a payé chaque
année l'armée américaine pour climatiser
ses militaires en Afghanistan et en Irak
le montant coïcide exactement donc ça
relativise un peu les choses une autre
base de comparaison c'est que c'est 0,4
% des dépenses militaires
cumulées du monde des pays du monde
alors tout cela pour gérer des
situations dont souvent personne ne veut
vraiment s'occuper des situations
parfois
gelées exemple que l'on peut en donner
c'est la question des hauteurs du Golan
encore que ça ait pas mal bougé dans le
contexte des événements en Syrie ces
dernières années on pourrait également
citer Chypre et voyez-vous sur Chypre on
sent depuis l'an dernier des
frémissements les partis chipriotes pour
la première fois depuis 50 ans ont
commencé à progresser vers un règlement
j'ai étis impressionné personnellement
par le l'engagement du président chipr
chpriote et du chef de la communauté
chipriote turque ils sont du même
village vous me dirait ça peut-être mais
il y a des normes contentieux à régler
mais enfin cette mission qu'on considéit
comme irrémédiablement gelée va
peut-être se dégeler plus tard dans
l'année c'est en tout cas ce qu'il faut
espérer et puis des situations de plus
en plus liées à des situations en fait
de crise essentiellement en Afrique
l'Afrique représente 80 % de nos
effectifs euh des crises actuelles ou
des sorties de crise et des processus
dans lesquels nous avons des mandats de
plus en plus
complexe qui consiste à la fois à
essayer d'amener une stabilisation de la
situation sécuritaire et dans l'immédiat
de et parallèlement d' veiller autant
que faire ce peut au respect des droits
de l'homme euh et à la progression de
l'État de droit alors alors certains de
ces processus en fait avancent bien nous
avons eu plusieurs réunions à New York
ces jour-ci il appartiendra au Conseil
de sécurité d'en décider dans les
semaines qui viennent mais nous avons la
perspective de fermer trois missions
dans l'année ou les deux années qui
viennent mission accomplie je pense à la
Côte d'Ivoire ou après les élections
présidentielles de l'an dernier qui se
sont passés dans de bonnes
conditions la situation est bien
meilleure alors je n'aurais garde de
mentionner évidemment l'épouventable
attentat de Grand Bassam il y a quelques
jours mais qui se situe dans une autre
problématique et d'ailleurs dans le
contexte de laquelle m'est-il revenu les
forces de sécurité ivoirienne ont été
plutôt performante certainement beaucoup
plus que celle du Burkina Faso après
l'attaque terroriste de wagadgou il y a
il y a 3 mois donc la Côte d'Ivoire
dossier quasiment en train de se clore
le Libéria également ce qui au passage
d'ailleurs une perspective beaucoup plus
réconfortante pour l'Afrique de l'Ouest
si on le compare à ce que la situation
était dans cette région il y a 15 ans
des massacres ethniques par milliers
dizaines de milliers des pays
complètement déstabilisés aux mains de
groupes absolument
invraisemblabl bon alors il y a de
nouvelles menaces il y a beaucoup Haram
il y a Al-Qaïda un peu plus à l'est mais
voilà je pense que les choses quand même
vont dans le bon sens comme elles vont
dans le bon sens en Haïti où malgré les
palinodies actuel qui se traduisent par
une incapacité pour le moment à terminer
à achever le scrutin présidentiel malgré
tout la situation s'est là aussi
beaucoup améliorée et je pense qu'on va
pouvoir fermer cette mission là aussi
dans les 18 mois qui
viennent alors reste évidemment les
missions les plus lourd les plus lourdes
en termes humains en termees financiers
et en terme de perspective alors il y
a le
secteur sahélien avec évidemment la
mission au Mali qui est complexe mais
dans laquelle je pense nous
progressons plus à l'est la Centrafrique
où je dois me rendre à la fin de la
semaine prochaine à bangi pour
l'inauguration du nouveau président
Fustin archange toidera et je crois que
là aussi malgré des difficultés on a
franchi des étapes
significatives et puis alors cet arc de
crise qui
va du Soudan Cartou le
darrefour au Sud-Soudan et qui se
prolonge sur la Corne de l'Afrique la
Somalie qui n'est pas une opération des
Nations Unies mais qui pose de
gigantesques problèmes et puis la
République démocratique que du Congo où
je pense on a progressé mais on est
encore un peu loin du compte donc je
vous l'ai dit nos mandats contemporains
ils sont qualifiés de multidimensionnel
parce qu'ils couvrent un spectre
d'activités considérable souvent
excessif d'ailleurs parce qu'en réalité
on en perdrait un peu le sens
des des
priorités mais en même temps c'est vrai
que il n'est pas
illégitime de protéger non pas seulement
les civiles dans leur ensemble mais de
projet matière de protéger de manière
spécifique les femmes les enfants tous
ceux qui sont les premiers à souffrir et
je dois dire que d'un mot
simplement personne ne s'y intéresse
beaucoup me semble-t-il en Europe ni
même en Amérique du Nord d'ailleurs mais
le conflit du Soudan du Sud est une
horreur depuis 2 ans bientôt et demi euh
on en est c'est mon estimation à 50 ou
60000 morts à
2200000 réfugiés déplacés c'est-à-dire
un/ ce de la population du pays des
dizaines de milliers de femmes violé
surtout que maintenant l'armée
sud-soudanaise a on le sait une
politique avérée d'utiliser le viol
comme instrument de conflit des dizaines
de milliers d'enfants recrutés de force
dans les différents groupes et une
incapacité du gouvernement comme de
l'opposition de l'opposition armée à
s'entendre pour faire avancer le program
le processus de paix qui a été défini
par les pays de la région dans le cadre
de cette organisation qu'on appelle
ligade j'étais à Juba avec le secrétaire
général des Nations unies il y a 2
semaines c'est scandalisé scandalisant
vraiment la manière dont ces
responsables politiques
euh non non' cure en à aucun titre en
aucune façon des souffrances
qui sont celles de leur peuple le Soudan
du Sud ce qui est maintenant le Soudan
du Sud a connaî a connu 30 ans une
guerre civile assez épouvantable mais
jamais à l'époque les sudsoudanais n'ont
souffert autant qu'ils ne souffrent
actuellement et en plus ils vont avoir
dans 3 ou 4 mois très probablement une
famine qui va affecter la moitié de la
population donc vraiment une situation
assez
décourageante dans laquelle nous faisons
ce que nous pouvons nous avons
200000 réfugiés sur nos bases parce que
si on les avait pas accueilis au moment
le plus chaud de la crise ces gens-là
pour la plupart seraient morts à l'heure
qu'il est mais qu'en fait-on et nous
sommes condamnés à gérer ça à la à la
semaine mais sans perspective d'un
règlement qui permettrait de dépasser
tout
cela le la République démocratique du
Congo où on a franchi je crois des
étapes décisives quand on a réussi à
reprendre le contrôle de Goma au Nord
kivou
de battre à plat de couture si vous
passez l'expression ce groupe dm23 qui
était en fait des des mercenaires plus
ou moins étrangers mais il nous reste
des groupes
extraordinairement tenac et et
redoutable je pense aux rebelles ADF qui
sont en fait des Ougandais réfugiés en N
kivou et qui régulièrement descend la
nuit sur un village etgorge 50 personnes
et repartent toujours la nuit pour aller
se cacher dans la forêt alors il y a
cela il y a les FDLR qui sont des
rebelles d'origine rwandaise il y a les
maillmaill de je ne sais combien
d'obédience et tout cela dans un pays
qui a retrouvé globalement une assez
bonne stabilité mais qui devrait
normalement s'orienter vers des
élections présidentielles en octobre il
est clair que ces élections n'auront pas
lieu en octobre et que tout ceci va être
générateur de tension dans un pays dans
lequel par ailleurs l'espace politique a
eu tendance à se retraécir ces derniers
mois et nous y étions également avec
bankyon dans ce même voyage il y a 15
jours on a dit avec beaucoup d'énergie à
président Kabila que il fallait
absolument corriger tout cela alors dans
ces opérations c'est vrai que il y a il
n'y a pas de modèle euh il y a toute une
série euh de formules différentes qui
vont de l'opération gérée par une autre
organisation je pense à l'opération
àisomme en Somalie qui est financée en
partie par les nations- unies par
l'Union européenne mais qui est mené par
les troupes africaines dans des
conditions d'è d'efficacité contestable
il y a l'opération mixte hybride que
nous avons au darrefour qui est une
opération cogérée entre les Nations
unies et l'Union africaine mais
intégralement financé par les Nations
Unies et en fait commandé sur le plan
politico-mitaire par nous enfin c'est
une opération quand même conjointe et
puis les
opérations su généris dans laquelle dans
lesquelles un pays ou un groupe de pays
a pris un peu le chef de fil la tête de
fil et évidemment le meilleur exemple
c'est le Mali dans lequel sans
l'initiative française au moment où
bamaco risquait de tomber entre les
mains des groupes djihadistes
bien je crois que on aurait une
situation encore beaucoup plus
catastrophique là ce qui est très
satisfaisant je trouve c'est que malgré
beaucoup de retard dans notre
déploiement on a une opération qui
fonctionne avec l'opération barce de
manière très très coopérative et je
crois que c'est ainsi que cela doit être
comme c'est le cas avec sangaris en
centra-afrique la centraafrique où en
plus nous avons eu pendant les 8 mois
critiques qui nous étaient nécessaire
pour monter en puissance le déploiement
d'une force européenne intérimaire fort
qui a joué un très très grand rôle qui
nous a donné l'espace et le temps qui
nous était nécessaire et je crois que
tout le monde s'y est retrouvé donc
voilà une série d'exemple historiquement
on pourrait citer la Côte d'Ivoire ù
sans le dispositif Licorne en 2011 en
2010 2011 je crois que on n'aurait pas
on se ne serait pas à l'heure actuelle
dans la situation de pouvoir dire que
nous allons fermer notre opération
prochainement donc je crois qu'il faut
saluer l'engagement de la France et
parfois d'autres pays la Grande-Bretagne
pour des raisons historiques il y a il y
a une douzaine d'années c'était
également beaucoup engagé en
sierraaléone et ça a permis là aussi de
sortir de l'ornière douloureuse dans
laquelle se trouvait ce pays alors ça se
traduit par une coopération je pense au
Mali je pense à la Centrafrique une
coopération extrêmement confiante
échange de renseignement échange de
plans
opérationnels coordination à tous les
niveaux et je crois
que ça nous a permis dans le casre de la
Centrafrique là aussi de voilà de mieux
occuper le terrain et maintenant que
sangaris va diminuer de manière
significative je n'ai pas eu l'occasion
d'en parler au cours des semaines
écoulées avec Jean ledriillant mais je
pense qu'il va y avoir effectivement une
diminution très forte des effectifs qui
restent encore de l'armée française mais
je pense que nous avons les moyens de
prendre le relais et en tout cas c'est à
cela que nous travaillons alors un
dernier mot monsieur le Président sur
vous en avez fait mention cet effort que
que nous avons eu au cours de l'année
dernière pour réfléchir un peu à comment
on pouvait faire un meilleur travail et
nous avons été aidés par ce panel de
haut niveau que présidait l'ancien
président du TIM oriental José Ramos
sorta mais nous avons été aussi aidés
par le fait que les États-Unis notamment
nous ont beaucoup aidé à tenir à la fin
du mois de septembre un sommet sur le
maintien de la paix auquel ont participé
une cinquantaine de chefs d'État qui ont
collectivement annoncé qu'ils étaient
prêts dans les années qui viennent à
mettre à la disposition des Nations
Unies jusqu'à 40 et même
45000 militaires et policiers et les
équipements correspondants et nous
sommes en train de traduire ces
promesses ces engagements en choses
concrètes pour à la fois accélérer les
déploiement dans le système classique
des nations- Unies puisque nous n'avons
pas nos troupe nous faisons appel au
pays contre contributeur et donc il nous
faut dans le meilleur des cas 6 à 8 mois
pour déployer une unité avec le nouveau
système que nous sommes en train de
mettre en place nous allons pouvoir
abaisser cela à environ 30 à 60 jours
dans les meilleurs des cas ce qui va je
crois quand même beaucoup changer la
perspective mais l'objectif n'est pas
seulement quantitatif il est aussi
qualitatif
et j'ai mené depuis que j'ai ce poste
une politique de recherche de la
performance la performance
professionnelle d'abord c'est-à-dire
que nousmes maintenant nous sommes dans
une situation qui n'est pas celle
qu'avait connu mes prédécesseurs quand
on avait besoin de troupe on prenait ce
qui se présentait et souvent c'était des
troubles tier monde qui étaient mal
équipé qui étaient mal entraîné
maintenant on a beaucoup plus de choix
j'ai beaucoup encourager les pays de
l'Union européenne au fur à mesure qu'il
se désengageai d'Afghanistan à se engagé
aux Nations Unies et je suis heureux de
voir que ça se fait d'une manière
progressive mais j'étais par exemple à
Berlin il y a un mois et demi le jour
même où le gouvernement allemand annoncé
qu'en appel en réponse à l'appel lancé
par la France au titre de l'article 427
du traité de Lisbonne l'Allemagne elle
est envoyé jusqu'à 650 personnes au nord
Malie et ça c'est quand même du dur
c'est du significatif pareil pour les
Hollandais pareil pour les Suédois il y
a tout un courant et même des baltes qui
viennent très sympathiquement me
proposer trois officiers je leur dis
parle français bah pas vraiment je dis
bon écoutez apprenezle le français je
crois que ça serait quand même plus
utile pour le Mali mais c'est bien il y
a il y a quand même une volonté de
répondre à l'appel de la France à la
solidarité et aussi de s'engager
davantage à nouveau dans nos opérations
donc c'est bien donc ça nous permet
d'avoir des troupes de meilleure qualité
mieux entraîné mieux équip
et aussi plus performante j'ai
maintenant une politique systématique
quand un certain contingent
national ne fait pas le job sur le
terrain et bien passez-moi l'expression
on les vire j'ai fait ça CIN fois au
cours de l'année écoulée au
darrefour ça m'a valu beaucoup de
reproches de la pass d'un certain nombre
de chefs d'État notamment africains mais
je crois que n'ons pas droit à l'erreur
n pas droit à laisser euh à faire rester
sur le terrain une unité qui se laisse
attaquer prendre en embuscade et qui ne
tire pas un seul coup de feu en ripost
ça n'est pas acceptable pas d'avantage
n'est acceptable la
conduite souvent inadmissible de
certains contingents et là ça Trouche
aussi bien l'usage excessif de la force
dans certains cas que les comportements
sexuels vous avez vu le l'avalanche de
cas que nous avons
découvert notamment en centra-frique bon
nous sommes nous devons être sans pitié
parce que surtout dans ce cas de figure
il est absolument inacceptable que cela
même dans la mission et de protéger les
civils qu'ils trahissent la confiance
qui a été placée en eux et qu'il en fait
qu'ils accroissent les souffrances des
civils notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de
viol ou est-ce qu'il s'agit d'affaire
qui applique des mineurs donc une
politique très très dure en même temps
il faut être constructif et donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous faisons
appel de plus en plus à la technologie
j'ai franchi un cap il y a 2 ans et demi
lorsque j'ai réussi à surmonter les
réticences de certains et à déployer
pour la première fois des drones de
surveillance aérienne au nord- kivou ça
a complètement changé la façon dont on
mène les opérations sur le terrain
euh mais on va
déployer des drones de longue portée au
normal au mois de juin et je crois que
c'est une entreprise française qui est
en train de rapporter le remporter
l'appel d'offre on a déployé à Kidal
toujours au normalie un radar de
contrebatterie talè qui marche pas
encore tout à fait mais enfin il faut
apprendre à utiliser tout ce système je
crois que c'est un investissement qu'il
faut faire comme il faut faire
l'investissement d'une politique de
renseignement le renseignement c'était
un mot tabou au nations- Unies on ne
pouvait même pas le prononcer
intelligence les gens étaient totalement
effarouchés
mais je crois que le fait de nous
trouver dans tant de ces pays africains
devant des djihadistes devant des
trafiquants de drogue devant des groupes
armés plus épouantables les uns que les
autres maintenant le membership accepte
que il nous
faut avoir une vraie politique dans ce
domaine donc j'ai nous avons bien engagé
les travaux là-dessus il me faut en
permanence des francophones et là
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais appeler votre
attention dessus je travaille beaucoup
avec l'OIF avec le président Abdou Diouf
en son temps avec Madame Michel Jean
maintenant mais nous n'arrivons tout
simplement pas à trouver suffisamment de
francophones pour des opérations comme
le Mali ou ou la Centrafrique à tous les
niveaux ça vaut pour les policiers ça
vaut pour les militaires et ça vaut
notamment pour les militaires de haut
niveau à plusieurs reprises j'ai eu
besoin d'un général africain francophone
ayant les étoiles le nombre d'étoiles
suffisants et dans l'expérience
suffisante et ben non à part le Sénégal
à part ici et là parfois un général de
corps d'armé qui a eu un parcours un peu
spécifique la ressource est très très
rare alors je sais que du côté du
ministère de la défense du côté du
ministère des Affaires étrangères on y
travaille mais c'est un chtier de longue
haline voilà je vais pe-être m'arrêter
là en signalant simplement que à quel
point nous apprécions euh l'effort qui
est fait par la France je dois dire ça
me ça me rend fier lorsque des décisions
sont prises sur le Mali sur la
Centrafrique de voir aussi la
contribution de l'armée française à la
finule mission si importante dans un
Liban qui pour le moment reste un peu
dans l'œil du cyclone malgré les
catastrophes qui se multiplient dans son
environnement c'est presque miraculeux
mais je crois que c'est très important
que la finule continue à assurer
he
son ce rôle qui a toujours été le sien
et je crois que tout le monde y attache
la plus grande importance voilà en tout
cas je crois
que la France a un mode d'intervention
aux Nations Unies qui est spécifique
hein des interventions souvent à titre
national mais couverte par un mandat du
Conseil de sécurité coordonné avec les
activités des Nations Unies
c'est une formule qui je crois a montré
qu'elle marchait qu'elle marchait bien
et on va continuer à travailler dans cet
esprit en tout cas moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé
pour aussi renforcer la la relation avec
l'Union européenne avec l'OTAN nous
avons eu la semaine
dernière une journée de consultation
avec l'OTAN et on progresse là aussi je
crois que avec ses grands partenaires on
va ue à avancer reste l'Union africaine
qui est un partenarat incontournable
parce que c'est sur ce continent que
nous avons 80 % de nos opérations c'est
parfois un peu compliqué mais je pense
qu'on on progresse quand même et nous
allons avoir l'Union africaine à New
York la semaine prochaine pendant 48 he
et on va essayer d'avancer sur tous ces
dossiers un peu
compliqués merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Secrétaire général beaucoup de sujets
beaucoup de questions alors tout de
suite la parole à Christian Cambon
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Secrétaire général des
précisions que vous nous avez donné et à
notre tour notre fierté de savoir un
français exerçant l'une des plus hautes
responsabilités au sein des Nations
Unies
avec tellement de difficultés à résoudre
moi je voudrais revenir un instant sur
les contributions financières et le
financement des OM c'est un discours que
vous tenez vous l'aviez tenu à notre
délégation lorsqu'on vous avez
rencontré quand on regarde la R itition
des contributions vous l'avez abordé on
s'aperçoit effectivement de qu'un
certain nombre de pays font beaucoup
d'efforts les États-Unis l'Allemagne le
Japon Allemagne et Japon qui eux même
par ailleurs paradoxalement ne sont pas
membres du Conseil de sécurité et puis
on s'aperçoit que d'autres grands pays
qui jouent un rôle important sur la
scène internationale je pense à la
Russie soit retard de ses paiements soit
ne fait manifestement pas partie des
plus gros contributeurs la Chine
elle-même doit contribuer moins que la
France je crois de l'ordre de 5 % un peu
plus 5 % quelque chose à peu près ça a
changé donc je voulais avoir quelques
quelques précisions sur la manière dont
les choses s'organisent car il est
évident que la multiplication des foyers
d'agitation et de déstabilisation risque
d'entraîner dans l'avenir un plus grand
nombre d'opérations comment allez-vous
faire face à ce financement et ne
faut-il pas procéder à une réforme euh
de du mode de contribution notamment des
principaux grands pays question annexe
qu' est pas vraiment du reste mais euh
est-ce que souvent on reproche à l'ONU
de d'être absent des des conflits
majeurs qui occupent l'actualité je
pense à tout ce qui se passe en Syrie
est-ce que vous pensez qu'un jour une
OMP viendra prendre le relais lorsqu'une
solution politique sera envisagée est-ce
que et lorsque les armes se seront tues
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Secrétaire général merci
pour cette présentation globale et puis
surtout je veux saluer votre engagement
pour rechercher la performance des
unités engagées dans les OMP et aussi
une certaine fermeté vous avez expliqué
les réactions que vous avez conduit et
puis cette incitation à une politique du
renseignement sans laquelle on ne peut
pas dans ces
difficiles être efficace je voudrais
vous poser trois questions rapidement
puisque nous sommes en train de réaliser
à quelques uns un rapport sur les une
approche globale des opérations
extérieures de la France et on se rend
compte que le volet diplomatique le
volet onusien est essentiel dans ce
cheminement voilà pourquoi j'ai des
questions qui sont plus accès sur
l'Afrique du Nord et la bande saélienne
en amont vous avez évoqué les
initiatives particulières de la France
lorsquelle souhaite déclencher une P en
même temps je voudrais savoir comment la
décision est prise et comment le mandat
le volume les capacités des forces sont
définis est-ce que le pays demandeur
intervient dans le cadrage de ces
opérations ou est-ce que c'est la totale
responsabilité des Nations Unies et de
vous-même deuxième volet c'est que nous
constatons et vous l'avez bien évoqué
une différence dans l'efficacité des OMP
et pardon si je suis peut-être en
désaccord avec ce que vous avez évoqué
autant les retours que nous avons sur la
minuska sont très positifs autant les
retours que nous avons actuellement
encore sur la minuspin sont insuffisants
47 morts l'an dernier au niveau des
trouples parce qu'il n'y a pas de
protection extérieure parce qu'on
s'enferme dans les bases et on voit bien
que c'est barce qui doit assurer la
sécurité ça a encore été le cas il y a
quelques jours et j'ai un de mes
collègues députés qui était à 8 jours au
N Malie qui est revenu épouvanté par le
manque de réactivité et de volonté
d'agir des forces de la minusma ell
n'assurent même pas leur propre sécurité
notamment la nuit et donc sont victimes
de tir de roquette de tir de mortier
alors qu'on voit bien qu'il faut qu'elle
se donne de l'air et l'arrivée des
drones allemands semble-t-il devra
apporter un plus sur la zone mais le
commandement compte la qualité des
troupes déployées compte aussi et on
voit bien que certains contingents ne
sont pas au niveau et donc comme vous je
salue l'engagement européen l'arrivée
des Allemands devrait légèrement
modifier les choses ça c'était le
deuxième volet le troisième volet que je
souhaitais
euh aborder c'est justement cette
nécessité de protéger soi-même avant de
protéger les autres donc est-ce que vous
envisagez d'aller un petit peu plus loin
dans le maintien de la paix en donant au
moins une capacité de combat rapproché
pour eu assurer sa propre sécurité qui
permettra en même temps de désengager
l'ensemble des unités présentes sur ces
territoires je vous
remercie c'est Daniel Rener
oui merci effectivement pour votre
présentation euh je vais me contenter
d'une seule question euh en complément
naturellement de celles qui ont été déjà
présentées est-ce que vous pouvez nous
décrire le processus de mise en place
d'une opération de maintien de la
paix c'est-à-dire à partir de la demande
d'où d'où elle vient la décision du
Conseil de
sécurité la génération des
forces le
choix de des choix logistiques
nécessairire ensuite les liaisons avec
les forces euh locales ou sur le terrain
et cetera est-ce que à partir d'un
exemple alors au hasard on pourrait
prendre la
minuskaa c'est la plus c'est la plus
récente qui nous intéresse nous allons à
banguy aussi dans quelques dans quelques
semaines pour faire un point dans le
cadre des opérations
extérieures
voilà
merci Françoise spérol Dubon oui après
mes collègues je voudrais vous remercier
Monsieur le Secrétaire général adjoint
pour cette présentation qui nous permet
de mesurer l'ampleur et la diversité des
des missions de de maintien de la paix
assurée par l'ONU euh j'aimerais savoir
euh lorsqu'il y a des processus
politiques en cours comment s'articulent
les les opérations de maintien de la
paix avec ces ces processus politiques
en cours et dans le prolongement des la
question posée par mes trois collègues
abordé par mes trois collègues
précédents euh vous avez fait référence
à la à la diversité si je puis dire euh
je ne dirais pas de qualité mais de
niveau de formation et de pratique des
des des troupes engagées euh lorsque
lorsque vous êtes amené à intervenir sur
un sur un un territoire n'y a-t-il pas
avant des prérequis qui sont posés entre
les différentes troupes et un minimum de
formation
commune merci Hélène conou met
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Secrétaire général pour ce
tour du monde rapide euh dans lequel
malheureusement vous avez rappelé
combien les les foyers de de tension et
de guerre sont nombreux vous félicitz
aussi pour votre votre engagement et
vous dire combien on vous soutient dans
cette tolérance zéro sur le comportement
des
troupes
qui je crois aujourd'hui où il faut
rassurer les populations locales qui
sont souvent anxieuses de l'arrivée de
cellees-ci au vu de ce qui a pu se
passer dans dans le passé je voudrais
simplement deux précisions sur les
questions qui ont été posé précédemment
par par mes collègues dans l'évolution
de l'engagement des nouveaux pays
quelles sont les motivations de ceci
alors j'ai compris que pour certains
c'était suite aux demandes que l'on
pouvait faire de soutien dans
l'engagement de de la France mais
qu'est-ce qui peut motiver certains pays
aujourd'hui de de s'engager quand il ne
l'avait pas fait précédemment deuxième
précision aujourd'hui il y a des
changements radicaux dans les
comportements des différentes forces en
présence je pense notamment au groupes
terroristes qui sont beaucoup plus
mobiles beaucoup plus connectés aussi
euh comment est-ce que vous vous adaptez
à ces changements qui sont très rapides
merci j'ajoute peut-être fa pourraz nous
dire un mot sur l'intervention des pays
quelques grands pays aujourd'hui la
Russie la Chine comment comment il se
positionne sur ces sur ces sujets
Nathalie Goul oui merci beaucoup pour
votre présentation bon les beaucoup de
questions ont été posées moi j'ai une un
petit tropis pour qui s'écrit de droite
à gauche donc quels sont vos vos
rapports avec l'Organisation de la
conférence islamique par exemple et et
et et ces organisations régionales parce
que de plus en plus on voit que les
Émirats et cetera participent à quelques
opérations et vous avez parlé de de pays
francophones mais en même temps il y a
des terrains où il faut aussi parler
arabe et où c'est mieux que que les gens
de culture connexe puissent être être
sur le terrain et et je voudrais vous
poser une question sur votre vision
d'une force éventuellement qui
interviendrait au Yémen qui est dans une
situation catastrophique et évidemment
la Palestine qui a totalement disparu
des écrans
radars droite à gauche d'habitude vous
êtes dans le sens de l'histoire chers
collègues jeanorjou
oui Monsieur l'Ambassadeur ça fait à peu
près 30 à 35 ans que je me pose la
question de
savoir pourquoi euh le nord kivou
litouri la vallée de la rouchourou au
confin du Rwanda et de l'ouanda sont
devenus une
zone non seulement de nendroit mais de
mort
permanente alors que finalement
lorsqu'on regarde l'ubumbachi qui
sangani
kanonga
badolité il n'y a pas de
raison plus importante indépendamment de
la rivalité tout si ou tout qu'on
connaît est-ce que vous avez une
explication intellectuelle
conceptuelle sur sur cette question
fondamentale parce que
euh le fait
d'intervenir d'essayer de
contenir de
recoudre éclate alors il y aura-t-il il
y aurait-il des forces géostratégique
géopolitique qui selon vous
est vu de votre bureau en altitude
permettrait de mieux comprendre que nous
qui avons crapauté dans ce beau pays
voilà merci à tous les intervelants
Monsieur le Secrétaire général c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président d'abord
pour répondre à la question qui a été
posé par Monsieur le Sénateur Cambon sur
le le
financement en
fait c'est un sujet qui revient
régulièrement à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée générale et qui est débattu
régulièrement clé de contribution alors
un processus hyper comp compliqué à la
fois technique et terriblement politique
mais le barê des contributions vient
d'être changé et vous serez intéressé
de voir le fait que la Chine est devenu
maintenant le second contributeur aux
opérations de maintien de la paix
passant devant le Japon qui reste le
second contributeur au budget général
parce que vous le savez pour les
opérations de maintien de la paix les
membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité sont taxés sont surtax il P 25
% de plus par rapport au barê régulier
donc tout ça change et je crois que moi
j'ai connu il y a 20 ans la Chine à 1 %
du budget des nations- Unies ben
maintenant elle est à plus de 10 et ce
n'est que justice pour reconnaître quand
même
l'augmentation de sa richesse vous vous
souviendrez monsieur le Président on en
parlait en Chine il y a quelques années
la Chine à l'époque de Louis XIV
produisait 30 % de la richesse mondiale
à l'époque de la évolution culturelle
donc début années 70 elle est tombée à 1
%. elle aspire à remonter sinon à 30 %
en tout cas à un chiffre plus en rapport
avec la constante historique elle est
actuellement à 10 % à peu près de la
richesse mondiale et bientôt 12 ou 15 je
crois que voilà ce sont des tendances de
long terme en tout cas aux Nations Unies
c'est reflété et je crois que c'est bien
alors allons-nous avoir plus
d'opérations à l'avenir d'abord je vous
le rappelle nous en avons nous allons en
fermer trois dans
les 18 ou 24 mois qui viennent au plus
tard et j'ajoute que nous sommes sous
pression de certains pays pour réduire
et réduire rapidement voir fermer la
semaine prochaine on va rencontrer le
gouvernement soudanais qui fait tout
pour nous dire le darrefour c'est réglé
il y a plus de problème il y a encore
des histoires ici et là mais c'est du
bruit de fond ce sont des querelles
tribales sécul
à quoi je dis pas du tout je ne sais pas
si vous l'avez remarqué mais il y a eu
ces deux derniers mois une offensive
énorme de l'armée soudanaise contre ce
qu'on appelle le dbel Mara qui est le
cœur du darrefour qui est le château
d'eau de la région qui est
accessoirement la base de repli de ce
chef de bande qu'on appelle Abdel Wahid
Nour une des armées de libération des
nombreuses armées de libération
autoproclamé qui se guerroi dans le
darrefour cette opération quand même
l'armée soudanaise y a engagé une
division entière et des hélicoptères de
combat et des jets et des bombardiers et
la conséquence directe c'est Queen
l'espace de 15 jours nous nous sommes
retrouvés avec 100000 réfugiés de plus
dans les périphéries de dbalma quoi
qu'il en soit le gouvernement soudané
veut nous convaincre que tout ça
maintenant est complètement banalisé que
la situation est rentrée dans l'ordre et
que nous n'avons
d'autres choix que de rentrer chez nous
en RDC monsieur le sénateur président
Kabila nous adore quand ça va mal je me
souviens la façon dont il m'a embrassé
et
traité quand nous avons battu le M23
c'était il y a 2 ans et demi il nous
adorait maintenant les choses vont mieux
il nous dit bon ben à bientôt enfin non
au revoir et et repartez donc c'est une
dialectique un peu compliquée mais la
question je crois est surtout celle des
des opérations nouvelles et là je
réponds au paravance à certaines
questions qui ont également été
posé moi j'ai pris une position très
claire la Syrie la Libye le Yémen ici à
ce stade ce ne sont pas des théâtres
d'intervention pour les casques bleus
pourquoi parce que d'abord il y a pas de
processus politique encore
confirmé une opération de maintien de la
paix des casque bleu c'est pas une fait
en soi ce sont sont des outils des
outils au service d'une vision politique
d'un projet politique d'un règlement
politique et tant que celui-ci fait
défaut ça n'aurait pas de sens on a
essayé d'inverser le les choses en 2012
doctrine en mais oui en 2012 au
printemps c'était kofianan qui était
chargé du dossier syrien par les Nations
Unies et il a conçu un
schéma qui consistait à dire on va
déployer des observateur des
casquesblele observate des militaires
donc non armé et leur déploiement va
avoir un effet vertueux sur les
différents groupes armés et on arrivera
petit à petit à bâtir des cesselfe
locaux qui de loin en loin vont
s'étendre et vont se rejoindre alors on
m'a demandé de déployer 300 observateurs
ce que nous avons fait un un temp record
on a mis en 27 jours c'était fait et au
bout de 4 mois on a tout plié parce que
ça ne servait à rien et on s'en est
rendu compte dès le début et c'est un
miracle qu'aucun de nos officiers euh
n'é été tués ou gravement blessé un
miracle non je crois que et Dieu sait
que le contexte de 2012 en Syrie était à
sans lieu en dessa de celui qu'il est
actuellement il n'y avait pas on ne
parlait pas encore de daesh hein on
savait qu'il y avait un peu d'alqaïda
mais enfin c'était plutôt des groupes
euh l'armée de l'opposition syrienne
armée qui était des des patriotes
malheureusement pour eux pas très
structurés hein mais on on s'est trouvé
à plusieurs reprises dans de ses
situations donc voilà je crois que ce
point est très très
important j'y ajoute un point dont je
suis heureux qu'il a été réaffirmé avec
force par le panel d'examen des
opérations l'an
dernier une opération des Nations Unies
n'a pas et ne saurait avoir vocation à
être un outil antiterroriste on peut
être amené et on est forcé d'intervenir
dans des environnements dans lequel nous
sommes
exposés aux terroristes on s'y adapte
mais nous ne sommes pas le fer de lance
au Mali le dispositif onusien c'est
clairement c'est cal nager barcade
maintenant qui est le faire de lance
antiterroriste et nous nous sommes là
pour essayer d'aider j'y reviendrai mais
l'autre exemple que je mentionnerai
c'est la fnuode de cette opération que
nous avons depuis 40 et quelques années
sur les hauteurs du Golan hein où il se
passait rien pendant 37 ans une fois par
an il y avait un chevreau et son berger
qui se perdait dans les dans les
barbelet et ça donnait matière à un an
de rapport et puis brutalement ils son
retrouvaient pris dans les combats entre
l'armée syrienne et différents groupes
armé avec des
kidnappés des gens menacés des vols de
matériel il a fallu repenser
complètement la mission qui reste pour
autant nécessaire parce que et Damas et
Jérusalem
continue à nous dire il y a assez de
problème dans la région on n pas besoin
d'avoir en plus le problème du Golan qui
reviendrait sur le devant de la scène
donc nous restons cûte que coûte mais
c'est pas facile et il y a un prix il a
fallu s'adapter à beaucoup de choses
donc voilà sur ces dossiers la Syrie la
Libye le Yémen même si les
problématiques sont un peu différentes
mais je persiste à dire que tant que ça
n'aura pas évolué politiquement de
manière significative vers un règlement
c'est pas nous hein alors j'aide les
envoyés spéciaux je leur prête des
conseillers militaires des officiers
généraux mais c'est très bien mais je
crois que on nira pas plus loin tant que
on n'aura pas vraiment avancé
sur le règlement encore une fois
oui quand les armes se seront tues
effectivement je crois que c'est bien ça
la
formule
alors la question de du processus de
décision et au fond vous êtes deux avoir
posé un peu des questions qui se
rejoignent là-dessus je crois qu'il y a
il y a il n'y a que des contextes
finalement spécifique il y a
d'abord le cas d'espèce dans lequel un
pays prendre une initiative forte pour
appeler le
l'attention sur une situation
particulièrement grave le Mali je crois
que la décision de faire intervenir cbal
a participé de ce processus de prise de
conscience
déclenché hein et déclenché de manière
volontariste mais il est aussi du rôle
du secrétariat du secrétaire général
dans certains cas de d'agiter la
clochette en disant attention il y a
quelque chose qui se produit là et qui
appelle une une réaction structurée
c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire sur le
Burundi hein l'an dernier quand on a
constaté à quel point la situation se
dégradait moi j'étais au mois de mai euh
à
bouavou et et je me suis dit mais si ça
vraiment ça ça barde au Burundi qu'on se
retrouve dans les scénarios de massacre
à grande échelle même si c'est en fait
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça personne
ne comprendra que les nations- Unies ont
20000 casques bleus au Congo à 30 km et
ne font rien à boujumboura donc sans
rien demander à personne mais
discrètement j'ai fait étudier des
scénarios dans lesquels dans des
situations extrêmes on pourrait
relocaliser tr bataillon de la Monusco
donc du Congo vers le Burundi dans
certaines conditions mais ensuite c'est
quand même à la fin des fins c'est aux
état membres et notamment à ceux du
Conseil de sécurité de prendre les
responsabilités et là les choses varient
beaucoup les États-Unis par exemple qui
ont joué un rôle crucial je crois et
notamment madame power savanta power
elle s'est engagé sur le dossier
centrafricain elle a voyagé là-bas elle
est revenue en disant c'est
catastrophique oui il faut faire quelque
chose
et je crois qu'elle a énormément aidé la
France à faire passer
politiquement le mandat de ce qui est
devenu la
minusca j'observe qu'en revanche la même
madame power pour laquelle j'ai beaucoup
d'amitié mais sur le Sud-Soudan et le
Sud-Soudan qui est quand même un peu la
création de l'administration américaine
et bien on n'arrive pas à les faire
bouger ils disent oui bah c'est bien
triste mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
et en plus il y a au moins trois ou
quatre positions de la administration
américaine hein donc dans une dernière
année de d'une administration sortante
ça facilite pas les choses donc ce
processus voyez-vous
c'est évidemment euh différentes
initiatives état-membres ou force
régional
ou
secrétariat une prise de conscience
politique et un accord du conseil de
sécurité pour dire oui on va y aller et
alors là c'est tout l'exercice de
définition du mandat qui est est
compliqué parce que c'est une
négociation chacun pousse les pions qui
lui sont chers ou les dossiers qui lui
sont qui sont pour lui
important nous avons nous-mêmes notre
possibilité d'injecter aussi notre
vision quand ça va trop loin ou quand ça
va pas assez
loin nous instruisons le dossier
techniquement c'est nous qui proposons
un volume de force un plafond d'effectif
au Mali par exemple renouvellement du
mandat dans un mois et demi on va
demander un relèvement du plafond parce
qu'on a besoin d'incorporer de nouvelles
unités et puis la
typologie des contributions qui sont
nécessaires les modalités de l'exercice
de génération de force on a des
principes normalement un voisin immédiat
d'un zone de crise ne doit pas être
accepté comme contributeur de troupe
mais il y a des exceptions c'est un peu
une géométrie au petit point qu'il faut
réaliser et puis ensuite il faut faire
passer ça au travers des différents
organes parlementaires notamment
financiers le pays haute n'a pas souvent
beaucoup à dire ce qu'on lui demande
parce qu'en général c'est un pays en
crise ou ou un état en défaillance à peu
près complète donc on l'écoute
sympathiquement mais on lui donne pas
nécessairement à ce stadel une énorme
voix au chapitre voyez enfin on essaie
de gérer ça au mieux mais à partir du
moment où les choses se normalisent
c'est vrai qu'il faut avoir un dialogue
confiant avec le Pays Haut parce que
sinon les choses se compliquent hein
alors la question de la réactivité
elle est essentielle c'est la raison
pour laquelle maintenant nous avons là
aussi différents modèles au Congo
RDC nous avons créé il y a 2 ans et demi
une brigade d'intervention composée de P
pays de la la sadeek en fait Afrique du
Sud Malaoui Tanzanie qui dans le cadre
de la Monusco dans le cadre de son
mandat il y a pas de mandat différent
mais a quand même une mission très
spécifique qui est de casser les groupes
armés l'expression officielle du Conseil
a été les neutralisés qu'on avait jamais
utilisé auparavant au Conseil de
sécurité et c'est ce qu'on est arrivver
à faire avec les
M23 pour les autres groupes qui sont
beaucoup plus diffus dans la région
c'est plus compliqué mais on y travaille
et je crois
que c'est cela il nous faut des troupes
motivées bien
équipé je me suis rendu un jour à
Pinga finfond du Nord kivou et le
colonel sud-africain qui avait
d'ailleurs un B nom français c'était
probablement un descendant du HUG euh
m'a montré un de ces jeunes soldats qui
avait 25 ans il me dit lui c'est le
numéro 2 mondial
du tir de précision militaire je dis bon
il me dit OUI OUI à 1700 m une balle
dans la tête ah ben j'ai dit bravo ça
c'est des moyens moi et parfois c'est
nécessaire il faut bien le dire hein
donc voilà c'est tout ça et c'est vrai
que dans le cas de la minusma on a un
problème constant c'est que nous sommes
la cible enfin Barkan et les Nations
Unies nous sommes la cible des
djihadistes qui veulent continuer à
mener leurs opérations à faire leur
trafic y compris la drogue hein euh donc
il nous attaquent tous les jours et du
coup 70 % de nos effectifs sont
concentrés simplement sur
l'autoprotection alors on a on va faire
changer les choses on est en train
d'amener un bataillon de logistique de
combat du Sri Lanka qui va avoir pour
mission de protéger nos convois parce
que l'une des difficultés c'est
l'allonge euh à travers ce pays qui est
quand même euh très grand hein et on a
des chaînes logistiques de 2 km et quand
on a une bombe une mine un ed euh tous
les quelques kilomètres c'est pas
évident et puis quand on est attaqué
c'est vrai les nuits de pleine lune il y
a une constante il nous bombarde au
mortier à la roquette tiré à
l'aveuglette c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous déployons des radars de
contrebatterie des hiostars c'est ces
ballons captifs avec des batteries de
capteur de caméras
on a fait ça pour la première fois l'an
dernier en centraafrique pour les
élections mais ça s'est trouvé coincidé
avec la visite du pape les service de
sécurité du saint-sège m'appelé deux
fois par jour dit vous aurez l'éliosta 3
jours avant l'avenue du Saint-Père qui a
été très importante politiquement dans
le contexte centrafricain et je dois
dire que cette machine B nous permet de
voir dans tout Bangui tout ce qui se
passe à tout moment et ça change un peu
la façon de travailler mais c'est un
investissement qu'il faut
faire euh constamment euh et c'est
important sur euh bon le l'articulation
avec le processus politique j'en ai déjà
parlé sur le processus mise en place
j'ai essayé également de traiter le
problème j'ajoute que lorsque je vois
l'Union européenne je saisis toutes les
occasions je participe maintenant tous
les 6 mois à la réunion informelle des
mises de la défense de l'Union je leur
rappelle que depuis l'opération Artémis
en 2003 qui a été une première dans le
politique extérieure et de sécurité
commune il y a toujours ce concept qui
flotte des des groupements opérationnels
des battle groups hein et que moi
j'aimerais beaucoup en tant que nuusien
euh qu'un battle group européen soit
enfin mis en place euh par exemple au
profit d'une de nos opération
l'opération de de transition en
centra-afrique on aurait très bien pu
choisir de l'appeler euh groupement
opérationnel bon ça n'a pas été le cas
pour des raisons théologiques parce que
certains et cetera et cetera mais moi je
reste très demandeur de ça parce qu'en
réalité c'est ce qu'il nous faut quand
il faut aller
vite au début d'une crise c'est là qu'il
y a le plus de victime c'est là qu'on
peut faire le plus de différence si on
est présent tout de suite donc voilà il
faut essayer
de et bah oui et c'est d'autant plus
dommage n'est-ce pas alors il y a de
nouveaux pays c'est vrai et le plus
frappant c'est celui que nous un que
nous connaissons bien monsieur le
Président c'est la Chine qui a franchi
des évolutions notables maintenant elle
nous fournit par exemple pour la
première fois une unité de combat au
Sud-Soudan du coup j'ai pris un général
de division chinois comme commandant
second de la force ancien second du
renseignement militaire à Pékin
excellent excellent général à tous
égards et de toute satisfaction et le
président chinois au sommet de maintien
de la paix en septembre dernier a
annoncé que la Chine allit mettre à
notre disposition une Force de réserve
de 8000 hommes 8000 hommes par rapport à
l'Armée populaire de libération c'est
minuscule c'est même pas 1 % pour nous
c'est énorme alors on essaie depuis
plusieurs mois d'en savoir plus mais
dans la grande tradition chinoise
l'empereur a parlé et il faut ensuite
que ça ça ruisselle jusqu'à la base ce
qui est en train de se produire donc je
pense qu'on va aller de nouveau à Pékin
dans de ou 3 mois pour en savoir un peu
plus mais je crois que le l'affichage
politique est très fort et très fort
l'affichage d'un certain nombre de pays
d'Amérique latine qui maintenant sont
demandeurs d'opération y compris en
Afrique à tonbouou notre escadrie
d'hélicoptère d'attaque c'est une
escadere que j'ai trouvé au Salvador
c'est quand même un peu paradoxal mais
c'est comme ça il y a de plus en plus
d'engouement engouement parce que les
gens veulent montrer que ils sont
engagés qu'ils assument le
responsabilité dans la communauté
internationale faut pas se le dissimuler
des motivations financi dans le casadre
certain pays du tier monde où
l'indemnité que nous versons
mensuellement est très supérieure au
salaire à la solde qui est servie par le
pays mais bon c'est une réalité mais
c'est vrai que pour des pays occidentaux
par contre non c'est pas du tout
çain enfin voilà il y a toute une série
de motivations mais je crois que la
l'altruisme et la volonté de montrer
qu'on s'engage dans la communauté
international est une réalité et puis
vous observez les négociation de paix en
Colombie dès lors que les accords de
paix seront conclus et à peu près mis en
œuvre les Colombiens m'ont déjà dit
qu'ils veulent venir vers nous et là moi
ça m'intéresse parce que ils ont une
capacité une expérience en terme de
combat de jungle un
d'hélicoptère
coordination solaire et cetera qu'
pardon alors c'est là le point c'est que
nous avons quand même une politique
aussi qui consiste à les gens quand on
les prend et à ne pas embaucher sous
casque bleu dans toute la mesure des
possible des gens qui seront une source
de problème de scandale de de toutes
sortes de critiques donc ce qu'on
appelle le vetting en anglais on
travaille beaucoup avec le Haut
Commissaire aux Droits de l'Homme pour
essayer d'éviter ce genre de situation
et c'est important
euh les autres grands pays bon ben je
crois que parmi les P5 la France est le
plus engagé euh même si au sein de
l'Union européenne l'Italie fait
davantage en terme de casque bleu mais
je crois que sur les CIN en tout cas la
France occupe la première place et c'est
bien les Russes ne font rien les Anglais
font marginalement ils ont annoncé
qu'ils allaient venir au Soudan du Sud
et en Somalie bon on va voir
euh et les
Américains pour toutes sortes de
raisons
juridique politique doctrine militaire
ils ont très peu de gens sous casque
bleu mais ils nous soutiennent beaucoup
de manière
latérale notamment en aidant au travers
de de très gros programmes formation
équipement en aidant des contingents
africains et asiatiques à se préparer au
maintien de la paix et ce sont parfois
des centaines de véhicules de blindé de
d'équipements divers qui sont donnés à
ces pays et quelque part on y gagne
quand même n'est-ce pas plus du Conseil
plus du renseignement à
l'occasion donc je suis assez satisfait
car de la manière dont ça se passe les
rapports avec l'organisation de la
coopération islamique bien sûr nous nous
voyons nous nous nous parlons le
problème c'est que au fond nous avons et
j'avais déjà fait allusion au début de
mes mes
réponses peu de sujets d'intervention
pour le moment dans le monde arabe nous
avons les vieilles missions entre
guillemets tradition
Liban Goan trève
enfin 1948 UNSO pour le reste nous
serons tributaires de des événements
politiques quand on a déployé cette
mission de supervision de d'observation
en 2012 en Syrie il faut s'en souvenir
c'était parce que la Ligue arabe et l'ci
avaient été incapable de le faire elles
en avaient discuté abondamment et ell
sétent retrouvé le bec dans l'eau et du
coup c'était tourné vers nous pour nous
demander de le faire et c'est ce qui
s'est passé donc on est un peu dans la
même situation même si maintenant la
Ligue arabe on va voir le Cher Nabil
alarabi vient d'être remplacé par AB
bullgate on va voir si qu' aura comme
nouvelle politique la Palestine ça n'est
pas pour nous madame salatrice vous le
savez voilà c'est bien et c'est un vrai
problème comme d'ailleurs je le
signale est un problème la question des
jeunes Sar oui au Sahara occidental le
même syndrome qu'à Gaza he des jeunes
qui n'ont connu que les camps de
réfugiés on a eu peut-être vous l'avez
vu ces derniers jours les choses
difficiles entre les Nations Unies et le
Maroc à propos du Sahara Occidental
parce que le Secrétaire général a été
quand même profondément scandalisé parce
qu'il a vu à Tindouf rabina et cetera
donc question là aussi il y a-t-il
va-t-il y avoir un processus politique
sur le Nord kivou monsieur le
sénateur
les explications on en voit certains
éléments on est conscient du fait que
toute cette région des grand lac pas
seulement le Nord kivou a été le théâtre
de ce qui a été au fond la première
guerre continentale en Afrique avec
l'intervention de combien de pays de la
région et d'au-delà hein avec des
chiffres absolument
hallucinants des millions de réfugiés de
déplacés des millions de tués on parle
de 4 millions probablement il y a 15 ans
hein et je parle pas des centaines de
milliers de femmes violées d'enfants
soldats recrutés et cetera d'ailleurs
tout ça c'est quoi c'est un conflit
d'intérêt entre des acteurs
régionaux hein et pour appeler les
choses par leur nom le rôle qu'a joué le
Rwanda par exemple dans certaines phases
de cette crise a été tout à fait
critique c'est à propos des ressources
comment expliquer que l'Ouganda et
d'ailleurs aussi a le Rwanda qui n'ont
pas de mine sur leur territoire
exportent et on le voit dans la
statistique douanière de l'or du coletan
et dans des quantités qui sont mal
négligeables ça veut dire que tout ça en
fait est
pillé dans le fond des forêts du du
kivou et et ensuite traité et exporté
par les pays voisins hein il y a des
groupes armés qui sont dans des des
espèces de délires ethnicau
nationalistes
hein enfin il y a il y a toute une série
de facteurs et justement maintenant des
situation qu'il faut
absolument essayer de régler je parlais
des rebelles ADF qui sont des Ougandais
et des Ougandais pas si éloigné que ça
de l'Armée de résistance du Seigneur
sauf que ils sont musulmans et qui sont
connectés maintenant avec les shebab
somaliens l'Armée de résistance du
Seigneur c'est aussi quelque chose de
invraisemblable qui ressurgit d'ailleurs
en centra-frique
oui un groupe transnational ltech qui se
déplace à pied ils n'ont pas de
téléphone donc on les suit à la trace et
il y a une centaine de troupes spéciales
américaines qui sont sur le terrain
depuis 3 ans pour faire ça discrètement
et parfois ils ils s'en prennent un mais
ces gens qui kidnappent 200 enfants ce
qu'ils ont fait en Centrafrique il y a
quelques semaines les endoctrines et en
fond des enfants soldats pour les servir
dans leurs intérêts qui sont souvent
liés au trafic d'or au trafic d'ivoir et
à de l'esclavage en fait donc beaucoup
de choses beaucoup d'interférences mais
je crois que la bonne nouvelle de la
visite du secrétaire général à Kinshasa
l'autre jour président Kabila a donné
l'ordre pour que nous reprenions la
coopération militaire enfin après une
année de gel et donc on va lancer des
opérations on est en train de lancer des
opérations je crois de grande ampleur et
j' j'espère qu'on va avoir le résultat
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre
l'audition d'ervé latsou le secrétaire
général adjoint de l'ONU en charge des
opérations de maintien de la paix je
vous propose maintenant de suivre un
tout autre sujet l'audition de melouf
mamesche qui est le président de la
Fédération nationale de l'enseignement
privé musulman une audition dans le
cadre de la mission d'information sur
l'organisation la place et le
financement de l'islam en France alors
la question de l'enseignement privé
musulman est importante aujourd'hui dans
le débat public quel sont les attentes
de la communauté musulmane en matière
d'enseignement privé quel contrôle
l'État exerce sur ses établissements je
vous propose tout de suite d'écouter
cette
audition pour la première fois je
rappelle qu'on parle vraiment et qu'on
pose le sujet l'enseignement privé
musulman en France qu'en est-il c'est un
sujet très important mais vous avez
poser beaucoup de questions qui sont
pour
moi très très importantes me permettez
d'abord de faire quelques remarques et
quelques observations générales
concernant l'enseignement privé musulman
en France première remarque c'est que
l'enseignement privé musulman s'inscrit
pleinement dans le paysage éducatif
français euh ceci ce manifeste sur deux
points premier c'est le respect des
programmes d'enseignement surtout quand
on est ce cont contrat d'association
avec l'État donc tous ces établissements
respectent le programme d'enseignement
même les établissements hors contrat ils
mettent ça dès le début dès la création
l'enseignement du programme de
l'éducation national deuxième remarque
c'est que cet enseignement respecte les
valeurs de la République se passe dans
le respect total des valeurs de la
République deuxème remarque c'est que
l'enseignement privé musulman est né qui
est né au début des années 2000 elle
répond un réel besoin scolaire c'est une
demande de plus en plus grandissante la
troisème remarque c'est que la
multiplication aujourd'hui des
établissements privés musulmans est un
vrai levier pour l'enseignement privu en
France et en aucun cas on considère que
ces établissements
euh qui sont considérés comme un repli
identitaire ou un refuge pour certaines
personnes de la communauté musulmane la
4è 4e observation c'est que les
établissements privés musulmans est un
lieu d'éducation et d'enseignement
d'abord pour réussir la scolarité c'est
pas pour l'apprentissage par cœur du
Coran c'est pas pour la c'est pas pour
apprendre les différentes sciences
religieuses mais d'abord ce sont des
établissement d'enseignement privé qui
s'inscrit dans le paysage
franco-français mais aussi c'est un
endroit idéal pour transmettre les
valeurs de l'Islam euh en parfaite
harmonie avec les valeurs de la la
République tel que le vivre ensemble le
respect d'autrui euh la paix l'amour et
c'est
l'endroit donc
idéal aussi pour lutter contre toutes
les formes du radicalisme et de
l'extrémisme ça il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on le soulligne bien c'est que ces
établissements sont un levier c'est
l'occasion pour lutter contre toute
forme de radicalisme et de l'extrémisme
quel que qu'elle soit l'origine
religieux philosophique ou autre la 5è
et la dernière remarque c'est que
l'enseignement privé n'est pas une
alternative à l'enseignement public pas
du tout on pense pas que les musulmans
créer leurs établissements privés
musulmans comme une alternative à
l'enseignement public mais c'est pour
pour offrir un choix aux parents aux
parents d'élèves qui veulent placer
leurs enfants dans des établissements pu
dans des établissements privés
catholiques musulmans juifs c'est
exactement c'est un choix à donner aux
parents et c'est ce qu'on appelle dans
l'éducation nationale le caractère
propre le caractère propre de nos
établissements c'est un établissement
privé
musulman et donc c'est une valeur
ajoutée dire aujourd'hui que ces
musulmans ils ont créé leurs
établissements établissement prév musulm
c'est un échec pour la politique de
l'intégration je dis c'est une réussite
pour l'intégration c'est que les
musulmans intègrent pour la première
fois à partir des années 2000 intègrent
justement ce système éducatif français
donc pour moi la cette intégration il a
réussi il a inclu aussi les musulmans
comme les catholiques comme les
protestants comme les juifs comme les
Laï comme les autres
euh composants de la société a créé à
intégrer ce système éducatif français
c'est pour cela le lycée A wouest à
Lille le groupe scolaire al kind à Lyon
le collège Ibn Khaldoun à Marseille la
plume à Grenoble éducation et savoir à
Paris toutes ces écoles tous ces
établissements se sont réunis pour créer
une fédération nationale à l'instar des
autres communautés euh le sgek pour les
catholiques
euh le Fond Social Juif Unifié pour les
Juifs et cetera et donc on a mis en
place c'est à l'initiative des musulmans
dans la perspective d'organisation
d'organiser justement et structurer
l'enseignement privé musulman nous avons
mis en place en 2014 en mars 2014 cette
fédération qui réunit aujourd'hui
l'ensemble à peu près des des des
établissements privés musulmans euh
l'objectif de cette de cette instance
euh c'est d'organiser bien sûr
l'enseignement privvu musulman en France
et surtout c'est être c'est d'être
l'interlocuteur privilégié des pouvoirs
publ et
euh mutualiser les expériences parce que
nous avons quand même une une petite
expérience en matière de création
d'écolees d'ouverture d'établissement
privés musulmans et on veut partager
cette expérience avec les porteurs parce
que aujourd'hui il y a environ 60
établissements privés musulmans en
France dans 6 ils sont sous contrat
d'association avec l'État mais il y a
d'autres projets qui qui qui qui qui
viennent chaque année on assiste à 5
6 nouveaux établissements privés
musulmans qui se qui se créent et donc
dès le départ on a on a on
a met en place cette fédération
justement pour accompagner pour
coordonner un peu les initiatives et
accompagner ce processus d'ouverture
d'établissement privés musulmans alors
quand je parle maintenant la commission
elle porte sur le financement des
établissements et et j'aimerais bien
placer àot sur le fin le financement de
nos établissements alors il faut dire
que pendant les 5 premières années
l'établissement elle est hors contrat et
donc il ne bénéficie en aucun cas euh
d'un d'une subvention quelconque de
l'État de la Région et cetera et donc
les premières années les cinq premières
années ce sont les porteurs de projets
que je salue au passage qu' assume et
pendant les 5 premières années euh le
budget euh de leur éétablissement ils
ont vraiment cette cette envie ils ont
vraiment euh le courage de mettre en
place un projet et de le financer de A à
Z ce n'est pas une mince à faire c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est un énorme projet
et donc au bout de 5 ans normalement on
passe le contrat d'association avec
l'État aujourd'hui nous avons que six
établissements s contrat avec l'État euh
don une une école à lîle le lycée av
verou c'est un contrat donc total euh
pour le LCÉE aves mais les autres
établissements ils sont en contrat
partiel quand je dis un contrat partiel
ça se peut que par exemple deux
établissements qui ont signé le contrat
avec l'État l'année dernière ils ont une
seule classe qui est sous contrat et
donc on ne peut pas dire on a six
établissements sous contrat mais on a
euh donc un établissement sous contrat
et les autres ils sont en contrat
partiel et vous imaginez le temps qu'on
MRE pour la signature de comp contrat
total chaque année on signe une classe
c'est le processus qu'on a engagé euh
depuis il y a 2 ans maintenant chaque
année on signe le contrat juste avec une
seule classe le le le groupe scolaire el
kindindiy à Lyon il a signé le contrat
d'association avec l'État depuis je
pense 2000 2000 2011 et ben jusqu'à
maintenant chaque année on signe une
seule classe une seule classe et vous
imaginez s'il a par exemple 20 classes
entre le collège et le lycée et ben on
va attendre peut-être 20 ans pour le
passage ce contrat de l'établissement je
pense que il faut faire quelque chose
pour le passage ce contrat des
établissements il faut un geste
politique fort j'attends du gouvernement
j'attends du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale de faire un un geste fort
vis-à-vis de ces établissements pour
rattraper le retard et pour justement si
on veut contrôler euh pas uniquement les
finances mais la pédagogie onit on
contrôle tout l'établissement je pense
que le meilleur moyen de contrôler ces
établissements privés musulmans c'est de
les faire passer ce contrat
d'association avec l'État
voilà maintenant vous avez poser
euh des questions concernant
euh les attentes de l'enseignement privé
alors nous avons soulevé la question de
du financement surtout
donc nos établissements la plupart il
sont hors contrat quand je dis 60
établissements il y a des petites école
parfois une seule classe de 15 élèves on
appppelle une école et parfois le plus
grand je pense le plus grand
établissement prévu musulman c'est le
licé avoisalil et puis il y a aussi le
groupe scolaire al kind à Lyon mais les
autres établissements on trouvent
parfois une seule classe deux classes un
niveau deux niveaux euh la plus plupart
de nos établissements c'est des écoles
primaires euh puis des collèges et un
peu moins les lycées il y a deux trois
lycées en France des des des lycées
prévus musulmans euh en matière de
formation des maîtres ça aussi c'est un
grand souci pour nous c'est un grand euh
chantier les autres
enseignements privés en tous des centres
de formation des maîtres que ce soit la
communauté juive ou ou pour les les
catholiques les protestants mais par
contre pour les musulmans donc on a ce
déficit au niveau de la formation des
maîtres au niveau donc du financement on
parle aussi du contrat d'association
avec l'État on attend à ce geste fort
vis-à-vis de la communauté musulmane de
faire passer signer le contrat
d'association avec l'État avec d'autres
établissements on attend que cette année
aussi on a fait la demande pour 5 ou six
établissements qui ont déjà 5 ans même
plus certains établissements ils ont
plus que 5 ans la période d'observation
et donc jusqu'à 10 ans et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas encore signé
le contrat d'association avec l'État il
faut qu' il faut qu'il y a un vrai
dialogue qui s'installe avec les
dirigeants de ces établissements pour
voir où est-ce qu'il est le problème
pour le faire passer ce contrat avec
l'État alors un autre point aussi qui
est important à monavis c'est pas parce
que il y a à chaque fois on entend une
école musulmane qui ouvre à
on dit il y a un problème quelque part
et puis on on met parfois les les
battons dans les roues on met des
obstacles pour l'ouverteur de ces
établissements parce que les
établissements privés musulmans et donc
on pense au REPL identitaire
communautarisme et cetera et cetera
toutes ces questions qui qui qui qui
reviennent qui pointent bien sûr la
communauté musulmane alors je vous
invite vraiment à euh ouvrir un dialogue
franc avec les les porteurs de ce de ces
projets et vous allez voir vous allez
être étonné euh à quel point quel degré
ces porteurs de projet ils portent dans
leur cœur et dans leur dans leur projet
les valeurs de la République ils
défendent B etle les valeurs de la
République et ce n'est pas vrai de dire
comme ça ce sont des porteurs de projet
attention c'est l'islamisme attention
c'est c'est le REPL identitaire
attention c'est le communautarisme
attention c'est l'enseignement du Coran
de de de la Sunna et cetera alors ces
établissements on insiste bien à travers
j'ai
visité pas mal d'établissements prévés
musulmanans j'aiété invité dans pas mal
de de de de de galas de dîner quand on
parle de de l'enseignement privé
musulman de rencontrre on a organisé
aussi plusieurs séminaires dans le cadre
de la FNAM et on parle et on met
l'accent sur pourquoi vous ouvrez un
établissement privé musulman si j'ouvre
un établissement privé juste pour dire
que les musulmans ils ont so 61 au lieu
de 60 62 au lieu de 61 ce n'est pas une
bonne chose ce n'est pas l'objectif à
atteindre mais ouvrir un établissement
priv musulman c'est de répondre à un
réel besoin scolaire bien sûr c'est que
il y a une forte demande et puis assurer
aussi la qualité de l'enseignement et on
a affiché pour nos établissements un
établissement pré musulman il faut que
ça soit ouvert à tous ce n'est pas
uniquement au musulmanans faut que ça
soit comme les autres établissements qui
sont ouverts à tous deè point un
enseignement de qualité c'est ça aussi
on on met on met le doigt on met
l'accent sur la qualité des professeurs
la qualité de l'enseignement en général
et troisème point bien sûr puisque nous
sommes un établissement privé musulman
on met le caractère propre aussi en
valeur et on dit que voilà on on
enseigne bien sûr la l'éthique musulmane
c'est déjà ce n'est pas une une une
matière obligatoire mais bien sûr on
essaie de transmettre C les valeurs de
cette grande religion alors le contenu
la dernière question c'était le contenu
et je répondrai aussi sur la question du
contrôle le contenu de nos euh
enseignements on l'a affiché depuis le
début que euh le programme enseigné dans
nos établissements c'est le programme de
l'éducation nationale
euh ça c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est une
réalité on reçoit dans less
établissements ce contrat des
inspecteurs
des académies qui viennent qui vérifient
euh les enseignements les diplômes et
cetera donc tout ça je pense il y a
aucun problème à cela on rajoute bien
sûr l'enseignement de la langue arabe et
la langue arabe c'est une matière euh
comme toutes les autres matières comme
l'espagnol comme l'anglais c'est une
langue vivante euh qu'on enseigne aussi
dans d'autres établissements pas
uniquement dans les établissements
privés musulmans
et on enseigne aussi les l'éthique
musulmane ou la religion musulmane comme
chez les catholiques le catéchèse et
puis chez les Juifs donc on essaie la
voilà la Torah et donc on essaie de
transmettre à nos à nos élèves ces
valeur aussi religieuse tel que l'amour
tel que le respect de troui et cetera
dernière question sur le contrôle
alors sur le contrôle nos établissements
ils sont ouverts à tous les contrôles
qui existe nous n'avons aucun problème
les portes il sont ouvertes seulement je
demande à ce qu'il y a un vrai dialogue
qui s'installe avec les porteurs de
projet avec les les les les les
directeurs de nos établissements et vous
allez voir que euh les portes il sont
toujours ouvertes maintenant je dis je
répète que la meilleure façon pour
contrôler les établissements privés
musulmans c'est de les faire passer ce
contrat d'association avec l'État et
comme ça les professeurs ils sont formés
les les professeurs ils sont certifiés
euh les inspecteurs ils peuvent venir
voir inspecter à tout moment
euh et
puis le fait de mettre les moyens pour
réussir je pense c'est un levier très
important euh de faire réussir
l'enseignement privés musulman je pense
que c'est c'est nous avons tout à gagner
euh le fait de soutenir de mettre les
moyens pour réussir l'enseignement privé
musulman peut-être oui monsieur si vous
voulez
compléter bien euh merci madame la
Présidente quelques mots pour me
présenter avant de de vous dire de
compléter le propos du président
Monsieur mamche euh vous savez moi j'ai
fait toute ma carrière enéducation
nationale je suis parti comme
instituteur et mon dernier poste a été
directeur de l'acadéine de Paris j'ai eu
d'ailleurs des académie comme l'Î
Villain ou lancement catholique était
très présent dans sous contrat et donc
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec L et dans
l'Orne évidemment pardon madame satrice
effectivement je suis passé dans l'Orne
aussi pendant 2 ans et donc j'ai eu
connu dans mes différentes fonction et
beaucoup lancement privé sous
contrat lorsque j'ai pris ma retraite
j'ai été appelé par le président de
l'association vos parce qu'il venait de
recruter un jeune professeur de
mathématiques dont il a fait le
directeur de lycée et comme ce directeur
évidemment n'avait pas de hiérarchie
puisque il était le seul lycée musulman
en France il n'avait pas comme les
directeurs catholique un directeur
diocésin il n'avait pas comme les chefs
les principaux les proviseurs des
inspecteurs d'académie ou des recteurs
pour les suivre et mais il m'a demandé
si voula êtes un petit peu son tuteur et
donc j'ai au début de à mon arrive au
lycée à vest donc j'étais un peu le
coach du directeur pour lu montrer
comment exercer un métier de che
établissement que j'ai été moi-même
puisque j'ai été aussi principal
proviseur inspecteur d'académie et donc
c'est comme ça que je me suis attaché à
vos puce que en travaillant beaucoup
avec le directeur à ma retraite et
ensuite en devenant un peu le conseiller
pédagogique de cette éblissement puisque
j'ai fais la formation des enseignants
la formation des parents d'élèves et la
formation des élèves donc je suis
extrêmement impliqué dans cet
établissement malheureusement depuis peu
le président du conseil
départemental du Nord m'a appelé à ses
côtés et donc je suis un peu moins pris
présent à ves mais surtout présent au
cabinet du président puisque je m'occupe
des questions d'éducation moi je voulais
vous parlerz d'abord un petit peu de la
fnem et ensuite vous parler de luliss
veres parce que je voudrais en être un
témoin vivant et comme la dit le
Président je souhaiterais vraiment que
sénateurs puissent venir le visiter il y
a déjà une commission qui est venue hein
qui est des sénateurs qui sont déjà
passés avec une commission chez nous je
voudrais vous dire quelques mots sur la
fnem nous avons en faisant cette F j'y
ai participé directement construit cette
fnem la Fédération nous avons installé
une sorte de charte qui s'appelle les
principes fondateurs de lancement privé
musulmans de France cette
charte nous demandons et j'aimerais bien
que cette charte puisse être annexée en
rapport si c'est possible parce que
cette charte vous montrera à travers les
propos qui sont tenus les écrits de
cette charte qui parle de l'enseignement
de l'éducation vous verrez qu'and est
fini cette charte elle montre bien
comment l'anement musulman s'inscrit
dans le paysage comme tu l'as dit très
bien Marou et en même temps comment moi
je me suis toujours dans cet
établissement en définité de mon arrivée
j'étais à la fois le porteur et le
garant des vurs de la République dans
cet établissement à la fois parce que je
suis un militant laïque davantage que je
n'ai aucune religion enfin je en tout
cas je nai pas de religion mais en même
temps j'étais dans cette éblissement
pour leur montrer que on pouvait être à
la fois un établissement confessionnel
privé sous contrat et en même temps
avoir et défendre constamment les
valeurs de notre pays donc je voudrais
si c'est possible que cette charte là
soit signée vous verrez que j'ai pas moi
d'en parler elle pr un islam du juste
milieu elle demande aux au fédérations
enfin aux établissements qui veulent y
adhérer ben de la de l'adopter et par
conséquent elle pr elle montrera avec
beaucoup de d'éclat combien cet
établissement est un établissement comme
les autres je parlerai d'avos après pour
dire d'ailleurs qu'à vos on a maintenant
des enfants qui sont pas musulmans qui
sont élèves donc je vous diraai quelqu
Mo
làdessus le problème de la de notre
notreenseement mus en France c'est un
problème de moyen c'est un problème
politique c'est on n'est pas dans un
cadre administratif on n'est pas dans un
cadre où il faudrait toujours avoir des
moyens je pense qu' on a besoin en ce
moment d'une volonté politique pour
permettre à l' musulm de se développer
la meilleure preuve c'est que nous avons
par exemple écrit la ministre le 4
janvier pour lui dire que nous
attendions toujours que les moyens
soient accordés à lancement musement en
France parce que cette année nous sommes
à 5000 élèves scolarisés dans
l'établissement buion près de 65
établissement une quinzaine qui se sont
ouvert à la rentrée dernière plusieurs à
peu près six qui peuvent passer sous
contrat et malgré nos instantes demandes
nous n'avons pas encore réussi à savoir
quelle était la dotation qui était
attribuée à l'anement musulman en France
pour la rentrée prochaine quelques mots
sur l'attribution des moyens moi qui ai
participé directement je peux vous en
parler le budget de l'État donne aux
établissements publics et privés les
moyens de fonctionner dès le mois de
novembre dans le la lo de finance euh le
lancement catholique connaît sa dotation
de mois de décembre et les
établissements confessionnels privé sous
contrat ou les autres établissements
laïques sous contrat d'association ne
connaissent pas leur dotation rapidement
parce que cette dotation est prise sur
ce qu'on appelle la
réserve il faut que vous sachiez que
l'État donne les moyens à lancement
catholique et tout ce qui n'est pas
donné à lancement privé catholique et
ben reste dans une réserve qui est
ensuite distribué alors là son souvent
des critères qu'on a jamais pu connaître
malgré le fait qu'on nous donne les
moyens qui sont distribués et cette
année par exemple la réserve comprend 70
contrats et nous ne saons pas encore la
date d'aujourd'hui quels sont les moyens
qui sont attribués à ces établissements
notamment au lycée aves qui a deux
classes de plus en terminale et dont on
ne connaît pas encore les moyens pour
assurer la rentrée prochaine donc nous
nous avons beaucoup insisté pour avoir
en temps utile comme lancement
catholique les moyens pour faire
fonctionner nos établissements cememb
pour l'instant nous nous sommes trouvés
confrontés
à non réponse pour pas dire autre
chosees je voudrais
enfin vous verrez on a fait une lettre à
la ministre qu'on a pas voulu publier
parce qu'après tout on voulait pas
polémiquer comme l'a dit clairement le
président la fnem si l'état fait passer
une classe par contrat par par année
sous contrat au collège avest il FAA 20
ans pour l'établissement sous contrat
alors que le lycée aves il est passé à
une seule fois
il est passé en une seule fois toutes
ces classes de seconde première
terminale sont passé à l'époque c'était
le préfet Canepa qui était à l'époque
préfet qui avait demandé à l'état
gouvernement son passage au contrat si
nous nous attendons une classe par par
an comme c'était ça se voit un peu
partout à Marseille ou à Lyon ou même
ailleurs notre collège av se mettra 20
ans pour être passé sous contrat je
trouve que c'est un peu
excessif encore un exemple et une
anecdote que je voudais pas rapporter
c'est que dans les cas où vous faites
passer une classe par niveau on arrive à
une absurdité c'est qu'au lycée Elkind
il y a deux classes de 3e il y en a
qu'une qui est sous contrat et vous
savez quand lesèves vont au breveret des
collèges et chis quelque chose et bien
s'ils sont sous contrat d'association
ils font comme les élèves d'ement public
de 3è ils ne passent que trois épreuves
et ils ont le contrôle continu par
contre les établissements qui sont
privés et qui ne sont pas sous contrat
doivent passer toutes les
épreuves dit dans ce lycée qu'est-ce
qu'on fait il y aura une un une classe
qui va passer tous les épreuves l'autre
qui va les passer comment choisir les
élèves et non nous avons souligné cette
contradiction auprès du ministre il faut
dire que nous attendons toujours à sa
réponse voilà voilà quelques mots je
voulais ajouter je voudrais si vous
voulez bien vous parler du lycée aves
que je suis donc de très près don je
suis vraiment au sens fort du terme
consil pédagogique je voudrais d'abord
dire avec clarté que dans cet
établissement euh ce n'est pas un
établissement qui coranique comme j'ai
entendu un jour le dire non lanement
musulm enfin la religion n'est pas une
matière de cet établissement au mieux
c'est sappéthique musulmane elle est pas
obligatoire et notamment pour ceux qui
ne sont pas musulmans puisque ce lycée
maintenant scolarise évidemment une
majorité d'enfants musulmans soit
pratiquants soit non pratiquants soit
des enfants de couple mixte et
maintenant depuis peu des enfants non
musulmans pour une raison simple que je
vais vous dire c'est que nous voyons
arriver des parents en 6e et en seconde
qui nous disent ben petit camarade nos
enfants rentrre au lycée ils sont
musulmans mais nous non est-ce qu'on
peut venir mais la réponse c'est oui la
seule chose qui nous qui nous contrarie
c'est que on a à peu près quatre fois
plus de demandes que de place pour
accueillir tout ça et c'est vrai que
c'est un problème pour nous dans cet
établissement au lycée aves je peux vous
assurer que contrairement à ce que j'ai
connu dans l'inement public et ce que
dit un inspecteur général que vous
connaissez peut-être Jean-Pierre auin
nous n'avons pas d'exemple d'extrémistes
parmi nos élèves nous sommes très très
présents dans cet établissement je
connais pas un seul cas de
radicalisation on a eu une alerte
quelques élèves de secondes sont venus
nous dire il y a tel élève qui su tous
les jours sur Internet la nuit des
émissions on on se pose des questions
pour elle il faudrait faire quelque
chose et bien nous avons signalé cet
élève à la cellule nationale de
d'antiradicalisation nous l'avons
signalé nous l'avons prise en main et C
des jeune fille maintenant est suivit à
la fois par nous mais aussi par les
cellules qui misent en place je peux
vous assurer que contrairement à ce que
dit avec méchanceté et malveillance un
profess sor de philosophie il n'y a
jamais eu d'antisémitisme au luces et je
peux en témoigner moi qui suis d'origine
donc je peux en parler j'ai toujours dit
au directeur comme au président de
l'association si j'avais senti le
moindre relant d'antisémitisme en
tempant que je seraai parti et je peux
vous en parler avec beaucoup de force
parce que justement nous avons toujours
voulu pratiquer le dialogue
interreligieux nous y participons
pleinement j'ai participé en 100ent an
dans comme responsable dans ce public et
bien dans cet établissement nous ont
venir UNAB nous avons projeté d'emmener
nos enfants à schwiiss et à berkono
bientôt tout ça pour vous dire que dans
cet établissement- là nous nous
cultivons avec force avec conviction
avec les professeurs qui sont tous
convaincus nous pratiquons avec beaucoup
de force ce respect de interreligieux
cette connaissance de la religion de
l'autre et comme disait jeanr le serf
nous sommes très partisans dans ceement
du fait religieux parce que dans cet
établissement dans dans ce cas-là
beaucoup d'établissements beaucoup de
problèmes seraient résolus quand les
enfants connaîtraient les uns les autres
les religions des autres et c'est pour
vous pour terminer sur un propos un peu
l'odateur mais je m'excuse moi qui donc
connais bien ce lycée de près je peux
vous assurer que c'est un
exempleétablissement exemplaire et
d'ailleurs les inspecteurs pédagogiques
régionaux de trans public qui sont venus
suivre la mise en place de lancement
moral et cque au lycée boucher ils sont
venus nous suivre mais après tout c'est
tant mieux pour nous nous ont dit que
Ben nous étions le seul établissement
d'académie qui appliquion avec autant de
Zè et autant de force ce nouvel
enseignement moral et civique c'est vous
dire par conséquent que cet
établissement c'est exemplaire et son
succès c'est pas seulement d'avoir faire
r sur ses élèves dans des proportions
exceptionnelles au baccalauréat out
après nous avons des enfants qui
arrivent des élèves qui arrivent
maintenant en fin d'étud d'année de
médecine d'autres qui sont déjà
ingénieurs on a des tas d'enfant qui
notre succès c'est pas seulement de les
faire r sur B c'est de les faire réussir
aussi dans leurs études supérieurs et
bien cet établissement ce qui fait aussi
son honneur c'est qu'il est devenu en
France un modèle et que c'est vrai que
nous sommes très sollicités par beaucoup
d'établissements qui veulent venir nous
voir pour dire on aimerait bien faire
comme vous aidez-nous et je crois que
c'est ça qui est qui est aussi pour nous
une grande victoire je dis souvent aux
musulmans que je rencontre pour moi le l
West c'est la seule institution
musulmane de France que je connaisse qui
a vraiment réussi et je parle pas des
autres institutions et sans porter de
jugement de valeur vraiment voilà donc
je voulais apporter ce témoignage
aujourd'hui à la Commission et je suis
prêt évidemment à répondre à toutes les
questions que vous souhaitez me poser ou
nous poser
d'ailleurs bien merci écoutz je pense
qu'on va passer maintenant à un temps
échange je vais prendre les demandes de
questions et donner la parole avant tout
à corapporteur Madame Goulet
alors je prends la L pour prendre le
micro ça va pas aller euh merci pour ce
vibrant plédoyer euh euh je vois que
vous avez gardé toute votre énergie
monsieur monsieur Soussan j'ai j'ai j'ai
plusieurs questions un peu technique à
vous poser Monsieur le
Directeur le le financement de la
construction et de la et de la mise en
place s fait comment et par qui euh le
paiement des le choix et le le paiement
des enseignants euh c'est fait comment
et et par qui et et leur rétribution
parce qu'il faut bien qu'ils a un statut
s'ils ont pas de s'ils ont pas de lien
euh et j'ai bien compris la rupture
d'égalité entre les classes selon
qu'elles étaient ou pas sous contrat et
euh et et finalement votre votre
pladoirie pour pour un enseignement
libre religieux musulman comme il y a
les catholiques et les et les et les
Juifs dans la dans la même dans la même
optique euh donc j'ai bien compris vous
aviez des enfants qui n'était pas
musulman donc j'en déduis que le voile
n'est pas obligatoire dans votre dans
votre
établissement je vous remercie de Me me
le confirmer est-ce que vous pourriez me
répondre sur ces sur ces questions
techniques parce que c'est quand même
extrêmement important puis que toutes
les questions de financement euh ont
toujours besoin d'être clair pour ne
pour ne pas soulever de de de suspition
donc plus les choses seront claires et
dites dans dans le casadre de cette
commission et plus nous serons à même
d'être efficace peut-être pour pour vous
aider plus tard
merci je vous propose de je vous propose
de répondre à Madame Goulet et puis
ensuite mes collègues s'inscriront pour
les
questions euh rapidement donc pour le
financement et la construction de nos
établissements euh il y a plusieurs
formes d'ouvrir un établissement
scolaire euh certaines ils ont commencé
euh au sein de la mosquée 1ier étage 2e
étage il y a souvent dans les mosquées
les liux de culte des salles de cours
pour l'apprentissage de la langue arabe
ce qu'on appelle les écoles coraniques
ou les écoles qui ensenent
l'enseignement de la langue arabe et
l'apprentissage du Coran dans les
mosquées et donc il y a des salles qui
sont parfaites qui sont bien bien
préparées et donc parfois on assiste à
l'ouverture d'un établissement collège
par exemple lycée au sein d'une mosquée
euh d'autres ils préfèrent de louer un
bâtiment dédié à l'enseignement pour le
collège ou le lycée euh voilà d'autres
s'ils ont les moyens ils achètent le
bâtiment s'ils n'ont pas les moyens ils
louent un bâtiment et cetera et puis euh
chacun comment il se débrouille pour
trouver un bâtiment adéquat pour
l'enseignement euh 2uxème question le
choix du paiement des enseignants je
pense que c'est le droit privé il y a il
y a des établissement hors contrat un
peu partout pas que pour les musulmans
mais pour les catholiques ils ont des
établissements hors contrat les Juifs
aussi ils ont des établissement hors
contrat et donc il y a un contrat entre
le le le professeur et l'organisme
gestionnaire de l'établissement et donc
c'est du droit privé mais c'est reconnu
en tant que tel enseigner telle matière
et cetera donc sur ça il y a pas de
souci mais je vous êtes sur une forme
associative est-ce que vous avez reçu
des fonds de l'étranger est-ce que c'est
des fonds d'une collecte des des des
gens religieux autour vous m'avez pas
pas vraiment répondu alors euh donc faut
parler du financement de l'établissement
pas uniquement de le paiement des
professeurs ça c'est oui l'ensemble il y
a il y a il y a sûrement pour financer
ces établissements qui qui qui
euh qui coûte cher vraiment euh c'est un
grand sacrifice alors on organise dans
nos établissements des soirées par
exemple dîner gala dîner caritatif pour
pour financer tel ou tel projet il y a
des collectes dans les mosquées on
appelle les fidèles par exemple à
prendre en charge tel ou tel à
participer dans le le budget de
fonctionnement dans l'achat de bâtiments
et puis il y a aussi le le le le le le
le financement qui Pr qui provientn de
l'étranger mais il y a
euh un financement qui est vraiment
c'est très difficile déjà on peut en
parler sur le financement de l'étranger
à l'étranger vous savez il y a que ce
soit et surtout dans les pays du Golf
euh des fondations qui qui aide à
financer euh et à mettre en place des
établissements privés musulmans comme la
banque de de développement islamique
basé à jeda euh la Fondation Qatar
charité euh au Qatar et d'autres aussi
organismes au kouwait euh et puis les
autres les Émirats arabes et cetera le
croisson rouge donc ces euh fondations
euh
on prépare tout un dossier le dossier il
passe dans des sphères différents et
cetera et puis à la fin
euh il décide à accorder un budget à tel
ou telle école c'est surtout pour
l'achat du bâtiment c'est pas pour le
budget de fonctionnement mais il y a
c'est vraiment c'est très difficile pour
arriver à S se faire et déposer et
avoir non mais monsieur le Président je
voudrais vous mettre tout à fait à
l'aise à partir du moment où l'État peut
pas financer la question est tout à fait
légitime c'est pas une inquisition de ma
part c'est juste pour savoir comment ça
s'est comment ça s'est organisé pour que
vous puissiez monter ce ce lycée ce
lycée exceptionnel ou en tous les
cas que vous que vous présidez donc la
question est tout à fait légitime ne
croyez pas que ce soit une une c'est
tout à fait normal à partir du moment où
vous pouvez pas avoir de fonds public la
question est tout à fait normale de
savoir comment ça a été financé encore
une fois c'est c'est pour de la transpar
c'est enfin ne voyez pas de mauvaise
intention dans ma question juste juste
cette année je rappelle que le Qatar l'è
du Qatar et la il a donné à la sband je
pense 2 ou 3 millions d'euros euh quand
il y a eu le problème des des des des
des réfugiés et cetera et donc personne
n'en parle par contre je constate que
c'est un établissement priv musulman
reçoit 1 million d'euros 2 millions
d'euros c'est voilà c'est le financement
provenant de l'étranger c'est l'islam
qui est pointti c'est on fait tout un
tout un débat là-dessus et toute façon
toute façon ce n'est pas interdit de
recevoir l'argent de l'étranger et même
on le dit euh seulement quand l'argent
il est conditionné on le refuse et on le
dit à voix haute on refuse l'argent
conditionné si vous pouvez euh
participer à tel ou tel édifice et ce et
cetera vous êtes les bienvenus mais il
faut pas que ça soit conditionné
enseigner tel Islam enseigner telle ou
faire telle pratique ça on le
refuse moi je voulais compléter madame
la Présidente par
quem je voudrais tout simplement
compléter par deux éléments le premier
élément c'est que le président de
l'association V a dit souvent quand
l'établissement n'était pas encore sous
contrat que le premier contrat
d'association qu'il avait signé c'était
avec les parents d'élèves et les parents
d'élèves effectivement chaque mois
contrib
par des dons ou par le coût de la
scolarité et bien au paiement des
enseignants au fonctionement
d'établissement et ce contrat
d'associationi avant de le signer avec
l'étage et signé avec les familles et
c'est vrai que notamment à Lille la
communauté musulmane de Lille avec la
grande mosquée était extrêmement
présente et il y avait une une
implication Terri formidable pour que ce
lycée vive et et réussisse et puis pour
compléter le propos de du président moi
je voudrais tout simplement dire que
nous avons été effectivement une fois
contactés par une grande fondation des
des pays du golf qui nous a proposé d'
d'acheter nos notre établissement après
de le louer et la réponse du président
et du directeur c'est dire non non nous
on veut pas de votre argent vous vous
achetez nos locaux nous on veut chez
nous et si vous voulez nous aider par
des dons on veut bien mais on veut pas
que vous puissiez prendre possession de
nos locaux puis ensuite nous le louer ou
intervenir dans le fonctionement voyez
ce que veux dire on enfin en tout cas à
VS on reste
extrêmement très très très très soucieux
de garder notre INDP je voulais dire
surtout par rapport aux pays qui sont
très preneurs évidemment de la notoriité
de notre
établissement juste pour répondre à la
dernière question concernant le voile
dans les établissements privés musulmans
euh on l'a dit et on l'a affiché que le
voile n'est n'est obligatoire ni
interdit c'est un établissement privé
musulman et donc ce n'est pas un
établissement voilé
foulardé loin de là mais c'est un
établissement qui est ouvert à tous
seulement il y a cette liberté pour les
filles voilées qui peuvent garder leur
voile ils peuvent garder leur voile tout
en ayant au sein de l'établissement mais
je constate aussi que quand on reçoit
des inspecteurs des visites euh j'ai
même vu un rapport écrit par un
inspecteur VO un inspecteur d'académie
comme quoi voilà j'ai rencontré la
directrice qui est voilée j'ai rencontré
euh le professeur de mathématiques et
mais entre parenthèses qui est voilé
mais pourquoi on rajoute cette ce
qualificatif est-ce qu'and on rencontre
un professeur dans un établissement
catholique qui porte la croix est-ce
qu'on mentionne aussi que nous avons
rencontré le directeur qui porte la
croix ou qui porte la quiipa ou ou mais
je ne pense pas par contre on se
focalise sur le foulard est devenu
aujourd'hui un point qui qui ne passe de
fixation qui ne passe pas
inaperçu alors j'avais trois demandes de
parole madame Durieux monsieur kurci
et Monsieur kucci
excusez-moi excusez-moi mais on a de
nombreuses heures de de débat et de
travail derrière nous et et de
nombreuses qui nous attendent
excusez-moi monsieur KCI et Monsieur
grosig Madame Dior
merci merci Monsieur
carochi Merci aussi monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur le Conseiller
bon je vous avez commencé votre propos
en disant le la création de ces écoles
privées musulmanes correspond à un
besoin réel scolaire vous avez dit par
la suite dont vous avez probablement
répondu qu'au programme de l'éducation
nationale vous ajoutiez l'enseignement
de la langue arabe c'était peut-être
l'un des besoins celui de la religion
c'est normal celui de l'éthique il y
avait-il d'autres demande ma seconde
question venez de répondre
euh le financement de la réalisation de
votre établissement vous avez dit par
les porteurs de
projets madame Goulet vous a posé des
questions précises et vous avez apporté
des réponses me semble-t-il précises
sauf si vous avez à compléter en tout
cas par rapport à l'argent venant de
l'étranger vous avez bien précisé qu'il
ne pouvait pas être
conditionné c'est normal qu'on pose
cette question qu'on pose cette question
en ce moment si parmi les porteurs de
projet il y en a d'autres à signaler bon
vous nous dites votre réponse sera
complète même si vous avez déjà fait une
partie de la la réponse peut-être pour
ma trème question aussi j'allais vous
demander et la mixité et la mixité et
donc je complète là aussi la question de
MAME Goulet comment la gérez-vous cette
mixité puisque nous avons quelques
problèmes dans le cadre de l'école
publique laïque à géré cette mixité
notamment les corps de gymnastique les
petites filles ou les jeunes filles quel
type de problème avez-vous et comment
les réglez-vous et enfin en ce qui
concerne le radicalisme et l'éducation
vous avez dit bon euh vous avez une
éducation sans doute qui est assez
complète pour anticiper vous n'avez pas
noté de cas de radicalisation mais
est-ce que au demorant vous faites de la
de la prévention il y a-t-il des cours
qui parlent de ce problème puisque c'est
quand même notre réalité aujourd'hui et
c'est peut-être cela l'objet de cette
commission et du travail qu'elle fait
merci oui c'est beaucoup hein monsieur
vous n'avez plus rien à dire oh là là
pe-être que vous pourriez poser vos
questions messieurs et puis ça
permettra
monsieur le Président moi j'entends bien
euh bon c'est un peu normal c'estàd que
si vous veniez ici pour nous dire que
vous étiez une difficulté dans la
République je sera assez
étonné personnellement moi je je suis
j'ai toujours été favorable à ce qu'il y
ait à côté de l'enseignement public
laïque et républicain un un enseignement
privé je trouve que c'est tout à fait
normal qu' un enseignement privé
catholique un enseignement privé juif et
l'enseignement privé musulman j'ai
vraiment zéro état d'âme en la matière
parce que les familles peuvent vouloir
autre chose qu'une éducation strictement
laïque il y a des familles attachées aux
valeurs religieuses dans toutes les
religions et c'est tout à fait logique
et normal et là-dessus franchement zéro
problème enanche vous comprendraz que
puisque cette mission est
essentiellement sur le
financement il y a une difficulté
j'entends
bien problème pour passer sous contrat
d'association
d'abord bien sûr qu'il y a beaucoup plus
d'établissements privés catholiques ou
juifs sous contrat d'association mais
parce que la création d'établissement
privé catholique ou juif est beaucoup
plus ancienne et que donc il y a 30 ans
40 ans 50 ans d'ancienneté dans bien des
établissements et là effectivement le
passage sous contrat c'est fait de
manière progressive d'ailleurs et et et
donc il y a une logique moi je pense que
dans 10 ans vous aurez beaucoup
d'établissements musulmans sous contrat
mais si parce que le système classe à
classe est tellement ridicule qu'il va
exploser et que c'est tellement absurde
que que ça ne tiendra pas et dans 10 ans
si l'existence des établissements privés
musulmans est est parfaitement intégré
au système de l'éducation nationale il y
aura un système de conventionnement et
de contrat d'association et ce sera la
règle comme pour les autres sera la
règle comme pour les autres et tant
mieux parce que c'est le meilleur moyen
pour que à la fois les inspections à la
fois les contrôles se fassent de manière
régulière en revanche il a un petit
sujet quand même parce que j'entends
bien dire oui on a le droit d'être
financé de l'extérieur mais justement
depuis le début de cette mission tout le
problème c'est de savoir comment
pourquoi le financement des mosquées
peut venir de l'extérieur comment
pourquoi un certain nombre de
financement peut venir de l'extérieur
avec ce que ça veut dire bien sûr vous
dites pas de financement avec
contrepartie ou gager ou bon très bien
mais dans un monde qui n'est pas idéal
qui est quand même celui dans lequel
nous vivons on peut légitimement se dire
que des pays des fondations étrangères
qui payent massivement
euh c'est pas totalement neutre et et
euh je j'entends bien c'est compliqué
parce que au début en tout cas euh la
communauté musulmane n'a pas directement
les parents n'ont pas directement les
moyens et pourtant il faudra bien mettre
en place un système mais est-ce que dans
vos rapports avec le le ministère qui me
paraissent assez difficile est-ce que
vous avez fait des propositions est-ce
que vous avez dit mais nous nous sommes
prêts à couper l'arrivée des crédits de
pays étrangers mais voilà comment alors
on pourrait trouver des solutions pour
que les familles musulmanes qui le
souhaitent et à leur disposition des
établissements privés musulmans en
fonction de leur capacité contributive
parce que problème je je le dis depuis
le début que soit pour les mosquées pour
le reste moi je suis pour un islam de
France totalement intégré et totalement
acceptter mais c'est évident qu'il faut
faire une vraie révolution dans dans le
système d'organisation de l'islam de
France si on veut y arriver et je pense
que à un moment la rupture avec les
financements étrangers en fera partie
donc est-ce que là-dessus vous avez des
propositions
oui
euh d'abord effectivement le
je comme ma collègue madame duriieux
voulais effectivement poser le le le
problème de la de la mixité et également
de du suivi dire de tous les
enseignements
euh on a des problèmes parfois dans dans
l'enseignement publique que moi dans ma
ville la la moitié de la population et
confessionion de culture musulmane donc
dans dans certains établissements c'est
3/4 des élèves euh on a parfois eu
effectivement ce type de difficultés la
contestation de certains enseignements
scientifiques au N d'une
conception dire très très littéraliste
corant comme comme certains protestants
contestent les T évolutionnistes en en
aux États-Unis
euh également sur la la la pratique du
sport pour les filles donc comment
est-ce que effectivement vous vous le
gérez euh après ça sur le voile fait
remarquer que dans les les les
établissement catholique euh les jeunes
filles sont aussi libres de porter de
voile et d'ailleurs et j'avais remarqué
presque en regrettant mais j'éta premier
auteur avec R Chenier à l'Assemblée
nationale de de de proposition de loi
interdisant les signes religieus
tentatoires au dans les établissements
publics d'enseignement et j'avais
remarqué comment à ce moment-là euh une
une fois que la loi avait été adoptée
j'avais vu l'inscription de beaucoup
d'élèves justement dans les
enseignements privés catholique pour
qu'elle puisse porter le voile sans y
être contrainte euh ensuite fr mararquer
à mes collègues que il y a aussi un
besoin qui est pas dit mais que très
souvent partie de la population
musulmane vit dans des quartiers plutôt
défavorisés où la carte scolaire fait
qu'on les envoie dans des établissements
dire qu' sont quand même moins bien
côtés que d'autres et donc cela
participe aussi on évoquait la demande
mais que la demande d'enseignement privé
participe aussi qu répond à la volonté
des parents de sortir les enfants d'un
certain déterminisme social et éducatif
du fait de de de leur lieu de résidence
sur la alors première question vraiment
sur le le sur la question de la mixité
auogéré 2è question euh alors le av os
en plus avec le le le nom que
l'établissement porte peut-être
exemplaire et c'est bien que la réalité
soit conforme au nom qui
imédiatement don une une grande grande
ambition savoir comment les les les
parents réagissent est-ce que certains
parents justement trouve que vous en
faites éventuellement pas assez on sait
comment peuvent tous être influencés
parfois par des courants parfois par la
télévision par Internet par est-ce que
vous avez ce dialogue comment ça se
passe est-ce que justement certains ne
vous reprochent pas au-delà et
deuxièmement quelle méthode il y a du
non dit effectivement dans dans cette
difficulté je suis pas aussi optimiste
que mon collègue Roger carucci sur le
fait que ça va se débloquer il y a une
vraie réticence il y a il y a une
réticcence d'abord je veux dire d'une
d'une laïcité que j'allais qualifier de
négatif d'État pour certains de dire il
faut absolument euh limiter ne pas
favoriser le développement
d'enseignement privé confessionnel en
tant que tel ensuite il y a quand même
une crainte de l'islam dit tout non dite
et de se dire tiens on va quand même pas
financer des établissements dans lequel
dire peut-être plus que dans les
établissements Israélites ou catholiques
peuvent voilà donc euh il y a ces
résissances non dites quoi dire alors
quelle est
euh pour vous la la part de de de de ces
rétisences non dites et qu'elle est la
part russi il faudra qu'on se la pose
des restrictions budgétaires quoi je
veux dire on est un budget constant quoi
on faut augmenter l'enveloppe elles sont
déjà pas trop importantes de quoi parler
temps qui court donc on on on a cette
difficulté supplémentaire enfin je
terminerai sur sur la question des des
des des murs moi aussi je suis pour la
construction d'un islam de France mais
j'ai toujours trouvé totalement
contradictoire euh euh cette
interdiction de financement public étant
d'un département concordataire jeis le
seul maire avoir construit une mosquée
municipale euh euh mais il y a cette
interdiction de financement par des
fonds publics et en même temps cette
exigence que je partage d'édification
d'un islam de France et s'il y a pas de
financement public compenu du niveau de
vie moyen quoi niveau de ressources de
nos concitoyens musulmans il y a souvent
pas d'autre alternative que le
financement par l'étranger alors vous
nous rassurez parce que tout le monde le
pose quand vous posez la condition du
non conditionnement précisément des
aides qu'en plus les aides ne concernent
que l'investissement et pas le
fonctionnement c'est moins dangereux par
dès lors que ça vous appartient ve dire
on est libre c'est c'est quand le le le
le financement étranger concerne le
fonctionnement que ça devient euh euh
dangereux euh et euh pour vous et je
terminerai là-dessus en partageant
amanasis CORG carucci si on voulait au
maximum couper le lien est-ce que on a
l'idée esquiss comme ça de de de
remettre en en vigueur la Fondation des
œuvres desam de France qui ne marche pas
elle pourrait peut-être être alimenté
par le halal ETA bien qu'il a les
besoins immobiliers déjà des deux de cul
qui seraient très importants mais même
si si on avait une solution de cette
nature est-ce que vous voyez après il
suffit pas d'avoir l'argent faut encore
le distribuer et compte tenu de
l'éclatement de de des des musulmans de
France est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
gérable et par ce système est-ce qu'on
pourrait financer les les projets
immobilier après ça l'État et les
parents finançant le
fonctionnement moi Jeuris je préfère que
les grandes questions générales soi
répondre moi j'aurais parler de la
mixité je voudrais répondre à vos deux
questions s la meexcité euh dans cet
établissement nous nous je parle à ver
mais je pense que dans ce des
établissements qui appartiennent à la
fnem le sujet le même nous nous sommes
toujours attachés à dire que
l'enseignement était obligatoire il est
neutre et que tous les enseignements
doivent être dispensés et en particulier
moi qui étais principal dans un collège
où il y avait éormément d'enfants de
témoin de Jéhova les parents me disaient
il est hors de question que nos enfants
apprennent la théorie de l'évolution
qu'ils viennent derère même le samedi à
l'école je me suis souvent insurgé
contre ses parents dis ben écoutez
quitte l'école publique à ce point-là il
faut aller ailleurs dans cet
établissement vs n nous sommes
d'ailleurs les inspecteurs viennent
régulièrement le voir et donc si par
hasard ils avaient trouvé des
manquements un lancement obligatoire
neutre que nous devons aux élèves il
nous l'auraiit dit en tout cas nous nous
sommes extrêmement attentifs et ça c'est
la la la la tâche enfin la tâche
essentielle que je donne au directeur
c'est d'être constamment à vérifier à
travers les emplois du temps à travers
les cayés texte les devoirs donnés que
nous sommes vraiment dans les clous des
programmes totalement pour ce qui est de
la mixité moi je peux vous dire que il y
a dans C établissement beaucoup plus
d'élèves non voilés que d'élèves volilés
il faut le savoir puisqueon a des
collégiens des lycéens on a des
enseignantes qui sont volé mais d'autres
qui ne sont pas d'ailleurs des
enseignants qui sont musulmanes d'autres
qui ne sont pas donc on a un mixage
total sur les questions de mixité je
suis très sensible à votre question
parce qu'effectivement c'est une des
choses auxquelles je me suis souvent
attaché avec le directeur et les
professeurs c'est que nous ne pouvons
pas accepter dans cet
établissement que des parents nous
disent ah ben non je veux pas que ma
fille s'assoit à côté d'un garçon et
d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises le
directeur a de convoquer des parents qui
av fait savoir qu'il voulait pas ceass
soir alors on leur a dit écoutez c'est
la règle dans l'établissement oui mais
il y a dans la classe on peut non non on
a dit on ne partage pas d'une côté les
garçons deautre côté les filles on se
mélange comment on envie de le faire et
ça c'est un point important parce que
même pour le PS nous avons des cours
mixtes et nous y tenons beaucoup sauf
quand les disciplines on se prêent pas
évidemment à à la discipline je parle
les discipline sportive évidemment ne se
prête pas complètement au même jeu pour
les garçons et les filles ça c'est une
une attention de tous les jours sur
mixité j'ai été moi une fois amené à à à
reprendre un professeur qui qui m'avait
dit mais non en définitive il faut
laisser lesurs enfants se séparer par C
j'aurais dit non à ce moment-là vous
n'êtes pas dans la vous n'êtes pas dans
les clous d'établissement vous pouvez
pas y rester parce que vous venant ici
vous vez des caractère propre et si vous
n'y suz pas ben vous pouvez pas y rester
donc sur la mexité on est très vigilant
je peux pas parler au de tous les
établissements musulmans vous vous en
doutez bien le président peut parler de
tous ceux au nom de tous ceux qui sont
dans la fédération qui ont signé la
charte et la charte dit clairement on va
vous la laisser mais après évidemment je
connais moi un établissement je donne un
exemple nous sommes tous les deux au
courant nous avons voulu aller dans une
école à roubé qui s'appelle arc-en-ciel
qui est une école musulmane qui a été
d'ailleurs faite par des convertis ou à
l'Islam et onelle nous a dit non vous
venez pas nous ne recevons pas d'homme
dans notre établissement donc vous voyez
qu'on a quand même des cas extrêmes
voilà et voilà donc il y a d'autres
questions concernant euh madame la
sénatrice l'a posé est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres
d'autres besoins scolaires
indépendamment dans l'enseignement de la
langue arabe et l'enseignement de la
religion de l'Islam en général oui il y
a bien sûr d'autres motivations qui
poussent les parents à inscrire leurs
enfants dans un établissement privvu
musulman euh il y a la proximité par
exemple il y a le port du voile certains
certains parents ils préfèrent que leurs
filles il gardent le voile ou certains
élèves aussi on a des élèves qui portent
le voile alors que on a les parents qui
ne sont pas du tout pratiquant et donc
ces élèves-là aussi ils veulent garder
leur voile ils veulent s'inscrire rester
dans un établissement privé musulmans il
y a aussi la réussite scolaire parce que
aujourd'hui les parents ils sont
conscients de la scholarité de leurs
enfants il y a quelques années euh
peut-être les parents ils étaient un peu
ignorants les parents n'était pas mais
aujourd'hui on a une communauté
musulmane qui euh donne de l'importance
vraiment à l'éducation de leurs enfants
et euh la réussite scolaire c'est le
défi à à à relever et le fait par
exemple le lycée avoisalil qui était
classé
premier en 2013 premier lycée en France
en 2013 l'année dernière elle était
classé 15e sur je sais pas 2400 2500
établiss donc l'Cie en France le fait
que il y a cette notoriété il y a cette
image euh de bah les parents ils font la
queue pour inscrire leurs enfants dans
cet établissement parce que il voi que
il y a le sérieux il y a l'enseignement
de qualité qui est affiché et donc ils
veulent que leurs enfants réussissent
leur scolarité ils sont prêts de payer
alors que juste à côté un établissement
public c'est gratuit mais il préfèrent
sacrifier vraiment on qu'on est des on a
au lycée av verouest environ 60 % des él
boursiier pour vous dire que la réussite
scolaire c'est pas c'est un défi
vraiment à relever malgré ça on arrive à
afficher de taux des taux de réussite
vraiment extraordinaire avec des élèves
qui viennent de milieux sociaux vraiment
très difficile vous avez donc pu suivre
ces deux auditions celle d'Hervé latsou
qui est le secrétaire général adjoint de
l'ONU en charge des opérations de
maintien de la paix et puis celle de
mlouf Mamèche qui est le président de la
Fédération nationale de l'enseignement
privé musulman vous pouvez revoir bien
sûr ces deux auditions sur notre site
internet
publsenat.fr